this is jocko podcast number 298 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
within weeks of their arrival
the seals of debt golf were shaking off
their initial jitters and even
displaying some measure of proficiency
signs of this were apparent in every
aspect of their operations on ambush
no one cleared his throat coughed spit
sneezed or even sniffled
on insert an extract the men stepped
heel to toe to reduce the sucking
explosion of mud walking and above all
avoided the footprints of the man in
front to keep from sinking even deeper
to improve their infield support the
seals befriended the pilots and crews of
the navy's helicopter squadron at na bay
and overhauled the seal's denuded
landing craft into an up armored
ironclad six heavy machine guns mounted
to the gun well donald's
a 60 millimeter mortar bolted to the
rusted deck plate and a bunker busting
recoilless rifle pinion to the top of
the sandbag pilot house
it was so much armament that the men
quickly recommissioned the lcm the
mighty moe
to it they added academy to block the
sun and rain a two burner stove for
meals then draped hammocks between
everything that didn't pivot or fire
essentially turned it into a houseboat
littered with empty hot sauce bottles
coffee cups clothes lines all aids to
reduce the number of trips back to nabe
and increase the amount of time they
could spend in a mission area
to improve the quality of their
encounters with the enemy
they experimented with a variety of
tactics false insertions that made the
viet cong think the seals that landed
where they hadn't false extractions that
made the vietcong think the seals had
left and probably most important squad
sized missions that half the seals punch
but correspondingly increase their
stealth and the amount of swamp land
they could cover thus doubling their
chances of viet cong contact
no small challenge in an area as empty
of the enemy as the rung sat
and what did these innovations yield a
handful of captured documents and north
vietnamese currency some fresh water
wells some rice caches one so monstrous
that it merited an air strike
then finally after more than a month of
frustrations debt golf landed a jackpot
ambush of two sandpans that killed seven
suspected vietcong gorillas
the seal's reaction was the same as
anyone who has just caught a hot streak
a little more than a week after the
first coup
one squad pursued a tip from the crew of
a hovering navy gunship that had spotted
several camouflage sandpans not far from
mighty moe's anchorage
despite having already blown their cover
in that area from several days worth of
patrolling the squad leader in full
daylight the squad landed in full
daylight and fell in behind point man
billy macon a keen eyed 28 year old
texan the father of a daughter and a
five-week
old boy he had never seen
stepping alone into the middle of the
sun drench clearing
and spotting a viet cong bunker macon
managed a single burst from his m16
before he was cut down by an eruption of
machine gun fire that left him stranded
hugging the ground to get under the rush
of snapping bullets and splintering
branches the seals fell back on their
training and clawed themselves into a
rough firing line but one that was not
nearly stiff enough to break the wall of
lead that blocked their way to the
fallen comrade
to tom truxell
engaged in the untested platoon
commander's perennial two-front war the
enemy and his own doubts it seemed that
the only recourse might be to pull back
to the river and to the mighty moe's
guns that is
until one of his men fired a 40
millimeter grenade into the bunker's
mouth
the shock forced a momentary flinch in
the enemy's ambush just long enough for
the heavyweight moscone to bowl a mad
dash from macon who is carried to safety
just in time to whisper a final message
to his wife while the corpsman ransacked
his tiger stripes to find his wounds
considering that macon's death was
considering that macon's death in combat
was not simply the first for the seal
teams
but that it was
also nearly a two percent manpower loss
for seal team one no one would have
faulted wires
if he had forced a pause to assess the
operation that had led to the tragedy
he didn't
the reason was no more complicated than
the same one taught to anyone who has
ever looked up to see the belly of the
horse that just bucked them off wires
ordered his men back to
back into their saddles and back into
the wrong sat
this perseverance would have payoffs
within a month the seals of debt golf
were expanding their operational
repertoire from planned patrol and
ambush to unplanned quick reaction
counter-attacks along the rungsat's
choke points
in theory it was an operational
expansion that finally fulfilled the
buckley report's recommendation for
riverbank raiders
in practice
it was a resurrection of the navy's
grapple swinging boarding parties
encounters now included the inland
pursuit and cornering of black pajama
wearing attackers firefights that varied
from a few sharp rifle exchanges to 15
minute skirmishes one of these against
an enemy packed haystack that did not
stop firing until the seals launched 48
grenades into it
before long the operational impact of
debt golf's aggressiveness was
considered so substantial that admiral
ward approved its increase from two
platoons to three all but a guarantee of
a corresponding increase in impact
while this blossomed so too did the
seal's confidence best evidenced by
their swagger around nabe
but also by a wooden sign above the
entrance to their tent scrawled
yea though i walk through the valley of
the shadow of death i will fear no evil
because i'm the meanest bastard in the
valley
though the helmets and flak jackets of
the un of uncountable gi's would soon
boast the same thing
by mid-autumn 1966 the seals claim to
meanest in the valley was undisputed
in the wrong sat
no other unit was as lethal
and that right there
is an excerpt
from a book
and the book is called by the water
beneath the walls
the rise of the navy seals and it's
written by a guy
benjamin milligan
this book is
a comprehensive history book about the
origin of the seal teams
now
that passage
hit me because i trained throughout my
entire career at a place called camp
billy macon out in the imperial valley
of southern california and i knew the
story of billy macon he was awarded the
silver star and they have that citation
out there at the desert training
compound
they also have pictures of his platoon
and btf tony tony of freddie and i we
used to inspect those pictures and we
used to look at bm1 moscone and he was
listed in that platoon picture we used
to talk about him and he was this
massive guy we stood out in the picture
and we used to think what would what
would bm1 moscone do right now in this
situation
but that really is
about all the information we had about
billy macon and his platoon and what
they did in vietnam some word of mouth
stories that we'd hear from some of the
older vietnam guys but that's about it
but this book
spells it out so much more and the book
details
the entire history of the seal teams
from the scouts and raiders to the naval
combat demolition units to the
underwater demolition teams
up to what we now know
and where i served my adult life in the
seal teams
now i normally don't cover
history books on the podcast because i
prefer to read first-person accounts of
people that were actually there people
that understand
what it's like to live through and
experience
things not just research it
well this book is an exception because
the author
ben milligan
was a seal
which adds a level of understanding and
connection that comes across on every
page of this book it is also so thorough
and extensive of the history of the
seals that it leaves no stone unturned
and connects
really to the soul of the modern day
seal
connects us with our frog men
forefathers
and
i think this book should be required
reading for
all all seals or anyone even remotely
interested in the seal so they
understand
where we came from
and the sacrifices that were made
to get us where we are today and it just
so happens that we have the honor of the
author ben milligan here tonight
to talk to us about his time in the
teams
and his amazing account of the history
of
the frogmen ben
thanks for joining us thanks jacob
uh
let's get a little start off by getting
a little background on you and where you
came from before we get into the
background and where the seals came from
let's figure out about where ben
milligan came from so so where'd you
grow up
indianapolis
northeast side
and and what was the uh situation you
were both your mom and dad do
my dad was an ear nose and throat
surgeon
worked in a small
uh town in uh indiana uh called uh
anderson uh it was a small uh uh
a gm town uh i think he was the only it
was him and uh one other uh ent in town
so he was kind of like
a
minor celebrity status
it wasn't a restaurant that we would go
to in town where
you know somebody didn't come up and say
hey doc thanks for you know such and
such hey doc i got a sore nose can you
help me out
yeah and at one point i think every uh
single member in my family except for my
younger brother worked uh in my dad's
office so we kind of grew up uh you know
in the in the medical field welcome to
welcome to doc milligans can you have a
seat over there would you like a candy
that kind of thing yeah i kind of i was
probably the uh uh the worst of my dad's
employees but he was kind enough to keep
me on
the worst example of nepotism
what um what about your mom did she did
she work was she house my housewife yeah
housewife she uh she looked after us she
was three boys and uh one girl so a fair
amount what number were you i was in the
middle so i have an older brother a
younger brother and then baby sister
okay so you're number two out of four
right
what about uh what sports were you were
you playing growing up uh
i played soccer uh badly uh i
i think they kept me on the team because
we are the the school that i went to was
so small they
uh they really had nobody else uh yeah
but i i didn't uh i didn't get to the
seal teams through any athletic ability
i was a really good tryer
so after uh at the end of every uh uh
soccer season uh when they passed out
awards they would always give me like
the mr hustle or
the most improved or some other
you know just sort of uh
you know under handle word
what was the
anything else going on in high school
what kind of music did you like well i i
ran track so i was i was a decent uh
decent attract but as far as music uh
that's typical stuff nothing no nothing
crazy nothing crazy nothing hip you're
looking at the like the lamest guy that
ever got through but
when you're so you said you ran track or
you ran cross-country or both i kind of
did a little both i i did uh uh
cross-country uh my freshman year what's
the longest race you run in
cross-country in high school isn't it
and only like three miles or so yeah
it's nothing nothing overwhelming and i
was pr i was good at it i probably could
have done that uh
i but after my how fast can you run a
mile when you're in high school
oh uh i think the fastest i did it was
something like 450 448 something like
that but the only reason i i i think
that was as good as i was ever going to
get i didn't
when i when i raced uh after every race
it was i mean i'd
dry heaving everything else i couldn't i
would get so nervous before the race
that i couldn't i couldn't eat i
wouldn't sleep the night before it was
miserable what were you nervous about
oh just brutal pain because i didn't
have the natural talent to do this so i
just gutted it out
so you were nervous about the suffering
you're going to experience yeah
[Laughter]
which made you suffer even more taco
show is tougher
and so
what
did you have any inkling about going in
the military when you were in high
school yeah i i knew that that was i was
going to do that i uh i think i i
announced to my parents that i wanted to
be a seal when i was 12. they didn't
know what a seal was
how did you know what a seal was
i'd heard my older brother's friends
talking about it and uh uh prior to that
my grandpa had been a marine in world
war ii so growing up until i was about
12 i'd wanted to be a marine
and then i found out what navy seals
were and then i i also
sort of found out right at the same time
that after the battle of okinawa my
grandpa had volunteered he was one of
the few guys that could swim and they
were so desperate for
frogmen after okinawa for the invasion
of japan that they had
ransacked the ranks just looking for
anybody that could swim and he had
volunteered for the udt so he was one of
the handful of uh
non-navy guys that actually uh joined so
he didn't do any operations as a frog
man but he uh he was uh attached to a
udt so
so you found that out but found that out
and and i was like well you know uh
impressionable age and like i i
i'm gonna do that so what was your
comfort level in the water
high comfort level uh he was um my
grandpa was uh um
i think we
we were at the pool every every weekend
uh swimming was a big part of our our
growing up and then
so
very comfortable but that never raced in
the water never never swam competitively
like i said before the school that i
went to was so small i think i had 54
kids in my graduating class i mean i
played soccer because there was no
football team
i ran track because we didn't have a
wrestling team or anything like that
have we had those i probably would have
done them but um i did what i could uh
but when i got to buds i you know
realized uh after hell week that i was
easily the slowest swimmer that had made
it through hoey i just didn't know what
the hell i was doing
so when but you didn't you go to college
after you're done with high school and
where did you go to college purdue
purdue studied history
is that what you knew you wanted to do
did you did you did you always have like
an affinity for history always yeah uh
starting uh
you know my dad was always uh reading to
us my grandpa was always reading to us
uh we would
as a family we would take trips and
often we were hitting a battlefield
along the way when i hit junior high
though right at that you know uh
consequential point in my life my
grandpa uh every uh every fall every
fall break he started taking me to a
different uh cup for you know the long
weekend he would take me to a different
civil war battlefield or some other you
know revolutionary war battlefield so it
just kind of got
uh
i just got
addicted so it was just i caught his
enthusiasm i guess so when you were
going to college were you
actually
learning and
putting see when i went to college i was
just doing what i was told to do i mean
i went i was already in the navy when i
went to college but i was just doing
whatever i needed to do to get good
grades i didn't care about anything i
just was doing what i needed to do get
good grades i wasn't like oh this is so
interesting i don't think i said that
one single time i was just like do i
need to memorize this cool give it to me
that was my attitude but it seems like
you might have had a different attitude
no no i if you uh at least were trying
to get good grades you're better than me
because i didn't care about that either
so i i mean i you're just trying to pass
well my so i had tried to enlist uh in
in the navy my senior year of uh
high school i hadn't shown up after a
soccer practice back home and i had gone
directly from practice to the
recruiter's office and i was getting
ready to sign on the dotted line because
i didn't want to go to college i wanted
to go right into the navy
and
uh the recruiter to his credit he um
uh stops me before i sign and he you
know he points you know obviously behind
me and he goes do you know that woman
i turn around my mom has both hands on
the window and she sobbed
[Laughter]
so
i
i took a pause we went out in the
parking lot my mom and i had a
conversation
and
she begged me not to join the military
nobody joined the military and our
family since you know world war ii so
when i got out there i said i would go
to one year of college uh and after if i
did that one year of college i would
have their blessing so when i signed up
for classes my first year
i had no i had no plan i just signed up
for every class it looked interesting i
signed up for the history of world war
ii i signed up for
uh i mean i i just i had no
i just signed up for all these history
classes and i went to the first one i
was hooked
and so you did kind of like your classes
i liked my history classes those are the
only uh classes that i paid any
attention to but i loved them and i had
i had great uh professors uh the history
and political science classes so there's
really no
military history classes or courses are
left in the country there's only a
couple of institutions that do military
history
um
so
they've they've taken a lot of that
military uh history curriculum and
they've kind of farmed it out to
different disciplines political science
being one of them um and so i would you
know just look for all these interesting
classes all the stuff that you know i
was interested in um
i managed to carve out a degree and when
i graduated in you know 2000 i i somehow
i managed to graduate in four years
[Music]
then i i tried to go to ocs uh
i had no idea what i was doing i had
never met another seal my application to
go to ocs and then get a buds contract
afterwards was ridiculous
i mean they asked you know on the
application and now i know you know you
need like an admiral or somebody to
write a letter a recommendation my buddy
fred i had my high school soccer coach
my application was pathetic
especially that was in 2000
oh yeah in 2000 the competition for the
officer billets is insane insane it's
insane so i just enlisted and
the freaking soccer coach just did
cutting
such a bummer
it was a very nice letter
so so then you
just said cool i'm enlisting yeah and my
parents did you know did your mom break
down again you know my parents were on a
trip uh when when this happened oh do
you want to she's gone yeah oh my yeah
my parents were gone um they knew how
important this was to me uh they knew
that i really didn't have a plan
afterwards it's not like i'd you know
been in some sort of apprenticeship to
you know go to law school or anything
like that i wasn't prepared for anything
so uh when
that when i hit that roadblock i called
my parents they were you know like i
said they weren't there i talked to my
dad
and uh my dad to his credit
just said this is something you have to
do and
so i went over and
went to the uh
enlisted recruiter and
i signed that day in two weeks so two
weeks later i was gone that's freaking
legit and what year was that two
thousand
so i i signed up in
uh
uh early august of 2000 i was gone by
the end of the month
that was 2 000 right
okay so you show up in boot camp
and you have that shock to your system
did you say to yourself what did i do my
mom was right oh yeah
[Laughter]
i was a college graduate
what the hell am i doing here
yeah but uh folding underwear
yeah i i mean i i didn't have the worst
boot camp experience they uh
um
early on they had you know uh asked her
if anybody here had uh college
experience and i had raised my hand so i
got made the the division yeoman so i
was able to kind of
leave from time to time carrying the
mailbag and just carrying the mailbag
for 45 minutes i would just march around
the base
yeah
so you get to
what was your uh
like pre-training getting ready for buds
did you do anything or you just
hey whatever yeah i've been uh i've been
following the
uh the buds uh pre or the pre-buds
training uh
plan uh like you know a certain number
of pull-ups setups uh push-ups
everything and then running and swimming
every day
so you felt like you were pretty good
shape no i i didn't i i thought i was in
okay shape uh and i'd been doing it for
a year and uh
um
so about four months before i actually
uh
joined the navy i had uh linked up with
the uh the purdue rotc guys uh that were
all training to go to buds and when i
linked up with them their training was
on a completely other level these guys
were serious they had you know they'd
met seals before i'd never met one and
so i did four months of uh uh training
with them i i i mean these guys were all
in rotc i had a ponytail i had a beard i
just i was just a looked like a piece of
[ __ ]
so
they showed up
like who the hell is this guy
you had a ponytail and a beard what year
i don't know
yeah oh yeah 1999.
uh but what was funny is uh a year later
when i graduated buds uh two of these
guys were sho we were checking into buzz
the day i graduated that's cool and i
burst into their room uh to say hi
and they had no idea who i was did they
make it they all made it yeah that's
awesome
do was any challenges in buds anything
that gave you a struggle
uh swimming uh yeah i had to uh
um
i i expected that uh swimming would
would be just like it was uh like
running was for me like you'd start like
running for for me if i was going to do
a long run
go out at a moderate pace that moderate
pace the further you go would get harder
to to maintain and then by the end of
the race uh
you know you're you're
physically taxed but you can you know
gut through the the last bit of pain
i swam like that i swam at a moderate
pace and by the end of it i was i was
pretty well gassed
um and it wasn't enough so i started
going every weekend in buds i was uh
linking up with uh
master chief nepper who i didn't know at
the time i mean i just knew that he was
you know a guy that would you know take
pity on all the shitty bud swimmers and
uh so when everybody else was relaxing
and kind of uh you know licking their
wounds from the previous week i was at
the pool with master chief nepper and i
would not be here uh or i would never
have made it through if it wasn't for
his classes and i mean little did i know
that you know he was uh i mean he's you
know one of the oracles of uh seal
history today
so so you
gra when did you graduate from buds
um
see august of uh
2000 yeah
august 10th
my my 20th year was or
2001 2001 yeah so you graduated august
and then where'd you get stationed
uh i was supposed to go to seal team 10
but i went to seal team four east coast
just some
paperwork mix-up or something yeah the
whole half of our class was going to
seal team five and the other half was
going to seal team 10 and for whatever
reason seal team 10 hadn't quite stood
up yet so they switched us to team four
so you
so where are you in september so you
graduate in august of 2001 where are you
where where are you actually standing
when when september 11th goes down i was
home having just completed airborne
so i i mean like everybody else in my
class i'm
i i
immediately went uh went downstairs
packed my bag and was ready to go and no
call came i thought you were going to
nom like i did we all did man i thought
i was going to nom in 1990 i got
we were going nowhere but disappointment
so you're at seal team four you
you get into a platoon what job you what
job are you in the platoon uh i was the
a 60 gunner pig gunner pig yeah freaking
new guy yep new guy no uh
no responsibility um
i was the uh i was the intel rep of the
platoon oh yeah that's right they were
like oh you went to college yeah you can
read right intel rep post
right
what kind of platoon so you're at team
four you're getting over the tune how is
it how's the work up you're having a
good time that was all right i like you
know the there were some leadership
challenges but uh it was a good platoon
i mean we had a good chief we had a good
oic um
we uh we didn't have a great mission we
were uh we were a marg so we got
attached to a uh you know a
marine um
what was it an lpd or lha something like
that and we were just sort of on call in
the med
um you know and at that point you know
both uh
afghanistan and iraq were going on it
was just you know we were sitting
sitting out in the in the med just
floating around we didn't do anything
until we we got called to go do liberia
as the
uh the liberian civil war so we did some
hydrographic reconnaissances and stuff
like that you got your lead line and
slayed out
i did right on i did and i was uh
so we had done uh probably half a dozen
of these things um and then the the last
one that we were doing was uh directly
in front of the um
uh the u.s embassy in monrovia
and um
i was probably the closest swimmer to
the beach which meant i was the closest
swimmer to the cnn cameras
they were out there and if anybody knew
my my history with swimming it probably
would have pushed me further back
uh but so i'm you know paralleling the
beach as we're doing this and i know
that you know the whole world is
watching and at some point i got wrapped
up in my lead line
like oh my gosh and i'm tied up in this
thing i can't swim the it's a really
close shore break so i'm getting
hammered with waves
i bounce my head off a big rock like
i've got to get out of this line so i
pull out my knife and i start cutting
this thing the wave is coming up on me
and i'm getting ready to get slammed
with this thing and i don't want to stab
myself while i'm doing this and so i
look around i got no i i'm holding the
uh the slate with one hand i got the
knife in the other and i need something
to swim with
so i did the only thing i could do i put
my knife in my mouth and i started and i
swam through the stroke like
how world war ii frogmen is
oh that's freaking awesome
so you you get done with that deployment
that was kind of the highlight of the
deployment was doing hydrographic
reconnaissance in liberia well i don't
want to brag but yeah it's freaking
legit
uh
hey i did two arg platoons out on the
west coast and i've done
so many hydrographic reconnaissances
it's ridiculous
but i guess
i've never done like a um i did real
once but they weren't in combat they
were like in kuwait we it was real like
someone was gonna land there
i mean but didn't get i never put my
mouth in my my knife in my teeth and
swam out but i think you could probably
agree it's not the reason you joined the
seal teams not quite why i joined the
seal teams
and that must be so what did you do
after that
uh
i had some you know sort of family
challenges so i uh briefly got out until
figured out where i was going to be
living when i finally found out i was
going to be living in san diego
i
put my
ocs package back together i really
wanted to go back to the teams and be an
officer soccer coach write you another
letter of recommendation i actually had
a few decent letters and i was uh
i just got into san diego i i contracted
uh in my you know during that year off
so blackwater triple canopy um
uh but where'd you go iraq iraq yeah and
what were you doing just psd basically
psd yeah
uh but once we got into san diego um i
uh
where where were you in uh where in iraq
were you in what years
uh well that was uh 2004
2004 2005. i mean i i was i guess it was
2005. i was back in the teams by 2006.
so what's psd personal security detail
yeah it's like doing security for
somebody so that's what a lot of the
contractors were doing you're doing
security for other government workers
those government workers could be people
working on telephone lines they could be
cia people they could be government
people
but
it's basically security gotcha so that's
what many of those contracting jobs were
for guys that were in special operations
just doing security
um
so you how long were you out for then
uh a year
then you come back in wait what happened
with your ocs package so i my ocs
package was uh i really just needed my
last letter of recommendation so i was
in the uh
the group one commander's office for my
for my interview uh he was kind enough
to give me an interview
i had been getting ready for that
interview for a while and uh the morning
of the interview i was
contacted by seal team 18 and said i was
recalled
so i was like well it's not the end of
the world but let's see if i can get
this you know uh ocs package signed off
on so just so everyone knows seal team
18 is a reserve seal team correct where
if you're in the if you get out of this
teams and you want to stay connected you
can go in the reserves and that's what
that is so you got recalled how many
teams are there like all together well
there's eight seal teams uh there were
eight seal teams at the time four on
each coast and then there's dev group
but then in addition to the uh uh eight
active duty team plus dev group there's
there were two reserve seal teams it was
sort of a new concept they they were
trying so they got eight teams plus two
reserve teams so 10 and then dev group
11.
yeah i guess essentially yeah kind of
there's some other things but yeah yeah
so because so when you say team that's
like a technical thing like yeah because
you got sdv teams too right
which are also teams gotcha
but the numbers though because that's
well you got the sdv team won an sdv
team too
so you got another two teams
all right this goes deep you can't leave
the sdv's out i understand the boys are
working hard they're working
um so i i'm in the office i'm i you know
i i knew that you know i had found out
that morning i was getting recalled but
it was still hoping that you know the uh
the captain could uh maybe figure
something out
so i do the interview interview goes
great i think and uh he's like do you
have anything for me and i said well sir
um not for nothing but i just got
recalled this morning i was wondering if
there's anything you could do you know
i'd really like to you know follow
through on this ocs package and come
back to the teams as an officer he just
said no that sucks
so i found myself back in the teams but
you know it was the best thing that
could have ever happened i went to seal
team five and uh
jumped on a great platoon with great
leadership and
you know
we we followed you yeah you guys
relieved us not my task unit but you
guys went to hobby
yeah yep
so you rolled out to habaneria and you
were a reservist that was activated yep
and they put you in a platoon yep well
that's freaking awesome it was
yeah it was great did you do any of the
work up or anything yeah
so you did the work up went on
deployment but you're a reservist but
you're in a platoon yeah what was your
job
uh rto our other radio telephone up i
was the calm guy did a little bit of
breaching but then you know kind of
taught myself how to be a jtac but
that's an interesting thing to try and
teach yourself while you're on the
ground in hobbies and not only that but
you know they you know i knew that the
platoon needed a calm guy
i've been to comschool and never been a
comm guy but they asked if i was a com
guy and i said
yes i'm the best company
i just taught myself how to do it
so it's a good call yeah
how was that deployment
it was great what were you guys doing
hobby in
0607 that was like the winner of 06 into
07 right correct what was your missions
were you guys doing we were doing a lot
of uh you know sniper over watches and
then uh
just doing it going house after house
you know
doing little uh little house to house
raids looking for al qaeda just like you
guys were yeah so you're kind of living
the dream
i was living i was doing exactly what i
thought i would be doing and when i
enlisted in 2000.
yeah yeah that's good i i always felt
that way when i was in iraq i felt like
i was
so
lucky to be where i was
and then i will say in ramadi it was a
little next level because you know when
you're a kid you you kind of
look i i was thinking nam you know my
whole life i was thinking nam right but
even there was something even a little
bit more seemed like a little bit extra
was straight up world war ii right
you're thinking world war two you're
thinking tanks and stuff so in ramadi
there was times where tanks were rolling
down the street rolling in in through
buildings over walls it was wwii
and man it was freaking awesome
um
yeah yeah but you're right i mean it was
i mean i i had that nom expectation too
and when we got there it was
uh it was a it was a ground war the only
thing that made it sort of nom-like is
the euphrates river oh yeah for sure and
we would use those stock r's uh to
insert and
you know there's only so many boat guys
on on the sock ours and sometimes
they're alternating between right or
port and starboard side guns so if they
didn't have anybody on you know a gun
you'd just stand up and you'd grab one
and uh yeah you're in a t-shirt and
rolling up the euphrates river and it
was pretty
there was an area a whole ao
called
1mc or mc1 i can't remember but it was
up north
kind of kind of northeast of the town of
ramadi and it was on the on the north
side of the river and it looked like nam
i mean
it was ridiculous plus we had the marine
corps huey's flying around
we called it viet ram because it looked
like it was ramadi but it looked like
vietnam and it was freaking crazy
uh
right on and
so you get done with that deployment and
then what what do you do when you get
home
uh at that point i uh i started
um thinking about uh grad school okay i
was
so you were a reservist so when you got
home were you released from active duty
kind of yeah i went to uh but i managed
to uh parlay that into going over to
warcom so i worked for a couple years
over orcom uh and i uh my platoon chief
from seal team five was going over there
to
run the jtac program
and you know i kind of taught myself how
to do all that so he uh he said if you
want you can come over work with me
while you're going to grad school and so
we just uh we just did jtac stuff for
the next two years while i went through
i got my degree
where did you go to school usd oh i i
went to uh undergrad there did you have
usd
gorgeous it's a nice place um and and
then were you thinking hey were you
still thinking about trying to put that
ocs package in or i was i mean i had it
was on the sort of the back burner i was
trying to decide whether or not i was
going to go uh put the
ocs package to go back active or
do like an fts package and uh get a
commission in the reserves oh check
so i had my first kid and once i had the
first kid i was like i don't want to
leave this guy
so
i uh i went with the reserves so i got a
commission so the day i
left active duty i uh i got a commission
in the reserves
oh so you did end up getting a
commission reserved i did you still have
it right now well i'm out of the
reserves now okay i left uh left the
reserves four years ago or maybe a
little more so
you you get done and now you realize you
want to stay home with the kid and
so then what you you're you're trying to
put your life together on the outside
how's that go
no great
like any uh guy who leaves the you know
their dream job uh and you know suddenly
finds themselves doing something they
never expected to do
uh it didn't go great jaco
i was you know like everybody trying to
figure out what my next uh
my next big thing was
looking for relevance in any any area
that i could find it and
i quickly realized that in my business
life i was not going to be successful
what businesses did you try well i first
off i started at a textile manufacturer
in philly we were trying to get back to
family uh because we had you know a
new new kid and probably another one on
the way so
my wife at the time lived in
south jersey so we we went there
so i got a job at a
textile manufacturer in philly and
they were great people and i really
liked the company and i was just
terrible at it
you know
they wanted to start like a tactical
product line and
um
i thought i'd try you know business and
uh
yeah i didn't do well
i didn't do terrible but i just like i i
don't i don't know what i'm doing
so i started thinking about this uh
right about then
i was like there's only two things that
i'm i can do
and you know
uh
i don't want to leave the kid uh and uh
all right you know at that time it was
you know one kid had become two
um
so i started thinking about this what
was the catalyst that made you actually
get out your computer open the word
processor and start typing
uh
that was
um
probably extortion one seven so uh like
everybody i went uh to
you know you know quite a few of the
funerals uh after that and uh
uh
i went to
uh jt's funeral john thompson he was uh
um he was from
rockford iowa so i went to his funeral
and uh
totally unexpected but when i was there
i met uh jim hornfisher or
james d hornfisher that's his author
name but he is uh he was a literary
agent
he was but he was also a
probably the
you know the greatest you know naval
historian in the country um he had
written last stand of the tin can
sailors neptune's inferno
so when i got to
jt's funeral everybody's there
everybody's drinking
i see this guy who's totally out of
place he's six foot five you know wears
glasses he's just kind of
not a team guy clearly
and
one of my friends uh quickly you know
realizes that you know he is
he has the two biggest nerds at the
event and he introduces us and uh
within 30 seconds i knew that uh um
this was a guy that was going to change
my life
so we started talking naval history we
got uh
uh got pretty lit up uh kept his
business card in my pocket for the next
year uh was kind of you know secretly uh
working on a on an idea for a book
and uh after a year i
uh sent him a cold email and just you
know here's a chapter uh one take a look
at it and uh he sent an email back and
he said this is fantastic and i spent
the next six months putting a an outline
together for what the rest of the book
would look like
and he took that to new york and
got a got a contract
so they gave me a two-year contract to
spend you know the next eight years
working on it so they gave you a
two-year contract yeah and you just kept
saying
i just kept thinking and going i just
got it
yeah no it wasn't that it was like i i
just
you know they they wanted they wanted a
product uh that i quickly realized i
couldn't give them
so i i knew that what did they want
they wanted they wanted a history of the
of the teams um but they wanted it done
quickly like everybody i mean you can
um
so i knew that if i did that then the
history that i was going to write was
going to be like every other history
that had been written on the teams sort
of just wave tops
and i knew that it wasn't going to be
written with any sort of intent beyond
you know just my own interest in each of
the events i knew i that i knew the
teams deserved
something
like this i just didn't know how to do
this
so
i
just kind of broke the whole thing down
i found a bunch of i found two or three
books that i really liked
i read each of them
three or four times
one of them i went through and i
literally outlined it you know not page
by page but like chapter by chapter it's
like this chapter is doing this this
chapter is doing this
and i just sort of broke it down how
does this author you know when i found
another author how's this author uh
introduce characters um how do they
you know how do they just you know
structure or how do they you know weave
multiple storylines together um and i
just kind of taught myself how to do
this
did you but i knew i knew that they that
you know uh this was gonna take me a lot
longer than two years so when they gave
you two years what did you did you just
signed the contract and just i signed
the contract knowing that you would yeah
i did the same thing i did at seal team
five you know
i said yeah i'm a calm guy
you said yeah i'll write this in two
years yeah
how pissed were they when you kept
missing the deadline by five years
they learned
you know to their credit they didn't
bother me
uh they would check in
and the only thing that they really did
was um
they uh they wanted to see the first
chapter
so once the first chapter was finished i
sent that off and
they said okay this is and it took me
between six and seven months to write
that first chapter on the raiders how
long how many hours a day would you work
uh i would start at 4 30 and i would
work uh until about eight
and then i would uh you know do the rest
of my day and then i'd come home i'd get
my kids to bed uh
and then once i once i put them into bed
i'd work as long as i could until i was
just kind of smoked so you're probably
getting like five six hours a day on the
book
yeah
for
yeah i mean i'll tell you what we will
get into the book now but
before we do the book is freaking it's
it's an incredible book and the detail
you go into
it's over 500 pages long i'll read a
fraction of that today um i i it was so
hard for me to
figure out what to
what what parts to read um you i i guess
i could have talked to you about it
maybe we could have discussed it but i
just kind of like there's every page has
got really important stuff on it um
the writing's terrific
clearly
and unmistakably you sourced it from a
lot of first-person accounts you know
captured documents or information
captured from documents from official
traffic from interviews from other
sources it reads like an action novel in
many parts except for the fact that it's
all true which makes it even better to
read
so this book i can't recommend this book
enough uh just a fantastic history and
it's not
it's not just about the seals because
one of the premises of the book
is that
seals wouldn't exist
if
either really the marine corps or the
army
would have
stuck to and committed
committed to the idea of having these
kind of direct action raiders which is
what the seal teams ends up being and
everybody's got it kind of got it now
you could say
but for many years there was many
attempts at doing this
and
they they wouldn't work out for various
reasons um maybe a mission would go bad
or a war would end or a combination of
those two things or you know when you're
in the army and you're a general and you
got some
some
cowboy looking guy running around and
you're a senior to that cowboy looking
guy you think i don't want this guy
running around i'm going to disband his
whole organization
or you're in the marine corps you do the
same thing hey you know i was in the
marine corps marine corps is right and
tight you know and now who's this guy
running around with freaking long hair
no i'm going to disband that whole
organization
and and that seems to happen a lot
there's one group
the navy
where
you're in the navy so you're sort of
you know if you're an admiral in the
navy
you kind of want to have some of these
hitters running around that can make
something happen and that's i think part
of the part of the genesis of the seal
teams so
book is fantastic um
let's get into some of this
so here we go
on august 8th at 0-900 both submarines
departed sub-base pearl harbor and made
it for the open ocean it was in the lead
was the nautilus with carlson and 87
raiders of b company following almost a
day behind was the larger and slower
argonaut with roosevelt and the
remaining 134 men the majority belonging
to a company for eight sweltering days
the raiders lived crammed alongside each
other anywhere they could stretch each
man a prisoner to to the heat sweat and
stink of the one next to him after two
thousand miles
of the pacific's
omnipotence slightly farther than new
york city to san diego the nautilus
finally arrived at its target on august
16th so these are marine raiders
group that have been put together to go
out they're conducting freaking sub
operations
in world war ii
um
fast forward and that's you know
obviously i'm only reading chunks of the
book so it seems a little bit stilted or
or
you don't recognize some of the names
believe me every person that's in this
book is described you give an incredible
background on people where they came
from how they got in the situation
they're in so when you hear me jumping
you haven't heard of a character it's
just because i haven't read i'm not
reading you the entire book
fast forward a little bit sensing his
momentum eroding like the ground beneath
him carlson sloth through the soft sand
hastening to gather his men before the
sun rose obviously they've been inserted
at this point
if he could find the un find and
untangle his two reduced companies and
point them in the direction of their
targets he might still have a chance
because there had been no reconnaissance
however no one knew for sure where or
where where they were or where to go
with four miles of beach to the left and
another six miles to the right with
targets their targets could be anywhere
if their targets were there at all
worse still one whole boat crew was
missing
without target locations or knowledge of
enemy strength
the 13 men
with 13 men unaccounted for and possibly
drowned carlson was blind and groping
for answers in an ever brightening world
his men becoming ridiculously
conspicuous along the white beaches in
their uniforms of dyed black so this is
already off to a bad start with these
guys yeah they
yeah i don't know what to say i mean i
uh the um
i didn't
write organizing the book i knew where i
knew i knew where i needed the book to
end
i knew that the book would end in
vietnam because in vietnam it's in
vietnam that the seal teams become what
they are today
land focus go anywhere commandos
what he didn't know was how it happened
and i didn't have like
you know uh in order to you know decide
what a book is going to be you gotta
have a you know not just an end point
you can have a beginning point so i
needed to find that first instance where
the navy um
wanted or the navy had that uh that
desire to create some sort of raiding
unit now
we all know that you know the marine
corps is a department of the navy so the
navy has its own army
and so logically the marine corps should
have been able to field that first
commando unit that worked directly for
the navy
the reason that they don't do that
ultimately
uh happens you know in the opening days
of world war ii and all happens because
of this make an island raid
the marine corps doesn't want the
raiders
the
marine corps wants what it's always
wanted or not what it's always wanted
they want what they've wanted since
world war one in world war one the
marine corps
becomes every bit as
consequential as the us army so the
leaders of the marine corps who all
fought on the battlefield in the first
world war they feel like when world war
ii happens
they can finally
achieve the status that their service
has long uh
deserved
so they're not interested in uh being
the navy's anything they're they they're
interested in being their own branch of
service completely uh
you know subservient to themselves
so when the navy says they want to uh
spread the japanese uh attention away
from the solomons or away from the south
pacific and do this raid marine corps
thinks well it's you know it's not
really what we should be doing but we'll
do it just because the navy wants it so
when it predictably when they send these
raiders up there
with a commander that the marine corps
really didn't wanted they really didn't
like carlson
it goes predictably bad and then the
marine corps justifies the reason that
they never wanted them in the first
place
it's it's interesting um even
and i don't know if you'll remember this
because it might be a little bit
you didn't come in until 2000 yeah
when i came in
the the marine corps attitude was well
we don't need a special operations group
inside the marine corps because all
marines are special yeah and that's the
attitude 100 their attitude and
they kept that like
to the t when i was in that was that was
just how they rolled
was was through that
um
yeah i mean they they have had that
attitude since the first well since
world war ii but it's in the first world
war they they realize what they can be
yeah
which is a parallel army
you
the the
the work that you did to research these
these battles and you go into so much
detail with them i mean here we're going
back to the book real quick
for the next 30 minutes a company fought
a suicidal enemy armed with four machine
guns two grenade throwers
automatic rifles and a flamethrower each
time the raiders managed to silence a
machine gun nest another japanese gunner
would step over the piled body
surrounding it and bring it to life
worst of all unseen and inescapable
where the snipers lashed to the tops of
the palms not blinded by the sun and
rewarded for their patience each sniper
sought out movement and took aim we
pleaded with thompson to stay down one
man remembered years laters there were
snipers within 50 yards of us he did not
compelled instead to shuttle between his
men pointing out targets as he went
his medal of honor was awarded
posthumously we had japs in front of us
above us alongside us to our left and
behind us remembered corporal young
exposed at the tip of
the cul-de-sac even when they managed to
fight free of the japanese around them
their good sense kept them nailed to the
ground i lay as fat as flat as i could
and tried to shrink myself as narrow as
possible said private glenn lincoln
playing possum under the palm trees and
the scrutiny of two separate machine gun
positions
in 30 minutes nine raiders from second
platoon were dead so was thompson
so was lieutenant jerry holtem
the battalion intelligence officer a
child of missionaries and the one raider
who could speak japanese also killed
were four radio telephone operators each
one singled out by the antenna waggling
above his shoulder which was connected
to a waterlogged radio that either
lacked the power to reach carlson's
command post or did not work at all
so like you said this is just a
a disaster
this this situation it's a disaster but
it you know it highlights you know
even though each branch of service has
uh leaders that have uh their own
purposes for creating these units at
various times for various reasons
in each instance whether it's raiders or
rangers or
lerps or whatever
the guys on the ground
these are
i mean
every bit is heroic and deserving of uh
you know our respect uh as the the seals
that their legacies ultimately funnel
into
so um
it's just
i mean the branches of service don't
support their efforts
for one you know various reasons and it
you know takes a long time to get there
but you're right you said it uh you know
in your opening remarks i mean this
this history or this institution the
seal teams could not have uh would not
have come uh to be
it would not have come to be a land
focused commando unit had it not been
for the gap uh that the army and the
marine corps and the cia
or the oss continually provide over this
30-year period of history
so that kind of
as you mentioned that kind of that first
raid that make and raid kind of put a
put a damper on the enthusiasm of the
marine corps to to go out and make one
of these units
um
fast forward a little bit you say this
in the book in may 1942 in anticipation
of the army's need the navy issued a
narrow call for volunteers to join
something called the amphibious
commandos
what made the call narrow was that it
seemed to be directed at a single group
that group was in the words of one
reported the 600 or so quote
educated muscle men who had signed on
as assistant instructors to the navy's
physical fitness program these were led
by the most educated muscle man of his
day lieutenant commander james joseph
green tooney am i saying that right
toonie tiny tiny
six feet tall equipped with a heavy fist
shaped chin and handsome smile that
every man woman and child in the country
recognized tawny was known
wait did i get that right tony or toonie
tony tony tony was known as the great
war machine turned heavyweight boxing
champ who had not once but twice
defeated jack dempsey unlike many boxers
of his day whose training consisted of
in the words of one competitor a haircut
and a shave tony had managed this feat
by relentlessly conditioning his body
during the day and by reading
shakespeare every night after winning
his secret second fight tony had fought
only once more then quit the ring
forever to follow what
to follow that irresistible pull as one
contemporary reported note reporter
noted to do something big in other
fields
this had included lecturing on richard
iii at yale and inventing the gene
tunney exerciser a long board equipment
a long board equipped with ropes and
pulleys that would raise the feet and
condition the abdomens it sold for three
dollars
[Laughter]
uh biggest of all he had swapped his old
globe and anchor for the bronze oak
leaves of a naval officer in order to
rid his new service of what he
considered its gravest threat the pot
belly
i dare say that fifty percent of the
officers enlisted men cannot properly
stand at attention said the newly
commissioned tony in 1941 partly blaming
their ill-fitting dungarees which
stretched too much and induced the
wearer to stick out his belly and hold
them up
tony reasoned that the problem was
actually a threat to national security
and would eventually lead in his words
to moral collapse
believing like all marines that a strong
physique undergirded a strong character
tony's initial efforts in the navy had
met with only moderate success because
sailors were not marines and as such had
never cared much for either fitness or
character
yeah your dry humor comes through a lot
in this book i had to cut i don't know
probably
five six pages of tony out i i mean
the one the one problem that you you
face when you're writing a book like
this is that you
research is really seductive you can go
down rabbit hole after rabbit keep going
you keep going you find article after
article after article and you want to
you want to cram all this information
into that into that paragraph
and it doesn't take you anywhere
so you constantly have to be asking
yourself what is this
first of all what's the book i kept a
note card on my desk uh when i started
working on the book and
the note card had three questions on it
was pinned to the wall
it said what's the purpose of the book
what's the purpose of the chapter what's
the purpose of this paragraph
and if the paragraph is not in support
of the chapter and if the chapter is not
in support of the
the book then you're not you're doing it
wrong
so um
i mean you every character that you come
across you you want to give them some
sort of uh sort of introduction tony's
uh consequential and that he uh attracts
all of these um
studs yeah he brings all freaking studs
uh
but he doesn't have the program that's
going to be able to contain these guys
uh so he attracts all these you know you
know pro football players uh to his
program um
that have you know they all want to you
know serve their country uh you know in
the most aggressive way possible and
they find out that they're going to be
calisthenics instructors
so of course you know what's going to
happen so tony collects all these guys
um and then you know i think the anyway
go ahead yeah it's it's
the
you know i've done a lot of reading
about sog and every basically i would
say every sog mission in vietnam could
be its own book you just want every
single song mission and that's the
feeling i get when when reading your
book
every one of these characters that you
introduce could be their own book yeah
just about every single character could
be their own book you just have to stop
you you've got to you've got to draw the
line at some point and be like yes
there's a book here clearly
but we're you know we're we're going on
to you know this objective i never
wanted to write a book with a thesis
that was never my objective i didn't
want to prove anything but what i did
find was that with the thesis uh with
the thesis i was able to
connect all these disparate stories i
never would have uh formed a you know a
comprehensive story
but with that thesis by asking the
question
how did the navy come to create a land
focus go anywhere commando unit i was
able to stitch all these other you know
rangers and raiders and all the other
stories of you know the non-seal units
into a book about the seals so
here's another character that you
introduce
um that we all in the seal teams
know
when 28 year old phil bucklew a football
star from columbus ohio had presented
himself at an army recruitment office
immediately after pearl harbor to
volunteer for the paratroopers the
recruiter had taken one look at a six
foot two 235 pound frame and said i
could i could take two instead of you
considering that the smallest soldier
the army could accept was a shadow
heavier than 105 pounds the recruiter is
absolutely right disappointed to be
passed up for the paratroopers and thus
lose his chance to be dropped into a
foreign land buckley had settled for the
navy then settled again for tu for the
tunney program
ostensibly the best place in the
military for someone with his background
after playing for xavier university in
cincinnati and then the rant for the
rams in cleveland buckley had since gone
on to raise money and recruit players
for his own professional football team
accomplishments that had demonstrated
not only intelligence and toughness that
tony sought but also leadership and the
risk-taking of an entrepreneur he was
not the only footballer with hidden
potential big john tripson a six foot
five bushy-haired all-american from
mississippi from mississippi state had
already seen more of the country than
most americans ever would having traded
his life on the south texas plains to
play all-pro tackle for the detroit
lions and robert herrick a mountain of
muscle from the mountains of colorado
who stacked every bit as high as his
texas colleague had enlisted in the navy
not only as a graduate of colorado state
but as its head football coach
essentially it was a roster with more
potential than tony's program could tame
[Laughter]
just a bunch of freaking beasts
got it got to read this part too so at
the call for amphibious commandos
buckley
and nine other titan athletes raised
their hands when they reported to their
next assignment a chief petty officer
with a knowledge of angling
and the tiny regime took one look at the
oversized arrivals and dubbed them the
tuna fish
the name stuck
um
you get another guy named
halperin in here who plays a huge role
in all this
yeah he's uh
indispensable
i mean i everybody you know
the the um
the temptation when you're writing about
these guys is to introduce them as they
come
you know you you come to buckle you want
to introduce baklu because buckle is you
know one of the most important people in
the history of nsw
you come to him you want to give him a
good you want to give them him the
introduction that he deserves but he
doesn't become
he doesn't become phil bucklow the
consequential phil buckley until vietnam
so you've got to hold your fire and
you've got to you know
sort of convince the reader that if you
just hold on we're going to get there so
because the most consequential person a
person of this period is the guy you
just mentioned which is buck halpern
yeah you get this guy buck halpern at a
mere six feet 225 pounds these guys were
monsters this is back in the day too
this is freaking like world war ii guys
are not jacked like they are now
like if you're six foot
six feet 225 back in the day you are
jacked 100 percent echo can you confirm
from the bro science perspective yes sir
okay just making sure at a mere six feet
225 pounds
robert buck halperin was easily the
smallest of the group but stood out from
his fellow footballers for a string of
peculiarities not the least of which a
face not unlike that of hollywood's
robert taylor besides this he was half a
decade older than the rest and had a
personality that was not only as dry as
cabernet but also incomparably
unflappable most peculiar of all he had
been raised and educated in the
exclusive chicago suburb of oak park the
second son of prominent jewish
immigrants at the time not exactly
features that encourage friendships with
working-class white footballers but try
telling that to halperin unlike the son
of jewish immigrants unlike many sons of
jewish immigrants halperin had been
raised to speak no yiddish to practice
no faith a boy so adrift from any
spiritual anchor that he adopted two
regional substitutes as his sanctuaries
the first had been lake michigan in
which he swam so often and so well that
he once caught the admiration of
awaiting al capone and upon which he had
learned to sail eventually reading the
windy city's win so well that he had
taken up competitive racing the other
sanctuary a high holy place if there
ever was one had been the notre dame
football stadium asked why a jew would
submit himself to such a christian
university halperin had flatly replied
because it was the best
so this is another guy um yeah uh he
just a character and he start i mean he
starts like you know from nothing he
doesn't he has no expectation he's so
old uh when world war ii starts he's 34
years old when he enlists as a seaman in
the uh
in the navy but his brother had been a
uh a radiologist um
uh at pearl harbor
and so yeah you know after you see your
brother you know you know performing
such service what else you gonna do
you've got to do the same so
he uh he pulls every string he can uh
gets himself into the navy and uh
i don't know i don't want to uh
give anything away but he
i mean he goes from
the tony program all the way to china i
mean he becomes you know nsw's first
ground force commander
it's freaking nuts um
last week of 19 august 1942 buck
halperin and the rest of the tuna fish
plus 36 enlisted sailors left the
solomon islands where they were trucked
more than 100 miles to a point where the
lower lip of the chesapeake bay met the
atlantic ocean here the virginia coast
gave way to an isolated tidewater inlet
called little creek and a dirt road
based with dirt floor housing that made
the solomon's look like san francisco
upon arrival they were greeted by an
army officer
lieutenant lloyd pedicore jr 29 year old
former commander of the observer group
who now wore knee-high leather boots of
a horse soldier
and in spite of his small stature when
standing at attention looked like a nail
waiting to be driven into a rail tie
his personality wasn't far off as one of
the few soldiers who had participated in
the marine corps flex exercises he knew
all too well the challenges awaiting the
men he now welcomed to the intensely
difficult course he had just created a
course of soft sand runs rubber boat
races and endless team calisthenics
known as the joint army navy amphibious
scouts and raider school at last the
navy's volunteers for amphibious
commandos were about to come them
that's sort of the beginning
and there's something you know what's
interesting i don't know i think if you
do those uh like psychological games
where or psychological tests where
somebody says something and it makes you
think of whatever you know you have to
say with it but when you hear amphibious
commando who's not 100 in on
that like when i think i knew what an
amphibious commando is when i was five
years old and wanted in
you know
i had the i had i collected these little
uh
air fix
soldiers the little 1 32nd size little
army men when i was a kid my mom
eventually threw him all the way by the
way brutal just a savage
i had hundreds of them
and i used to you know dream and talk
and play with those things but my
favorite was the british commandos they
had little zodiacs and kayaks
and little uh beanie caps
like that was the deal
and you see that that was when i was a
little kid that was like
amphibious commandos
ah
so
again i can't read this whole book but
yeah uh pedicore like he's a
uh
each of the people that i
focus on in the book um
i
i tried to drill down as as close as i
could uh
you know you there's you know
the general rule of thumb is you start
big and you go small so you read
whatever is available the existing
literature that's out there
uh and there have been there have been a
couple of books that have been published
in paddy chords of characters so you
kind of trace those down uh you know
pedicore halper and buckley whatever
you're you're trying to get as close as
you can to
the person that you want to write about
or the the person that becomes the
consequential person of the moment so
you're trying to learn about them in
such a way that you can find out the
traits in that person
that made them consequential um and
whether the the traits that made you
know somebody like carlson uh a failure
or the traits that made pedicore or
buckley or halpern a success
so uh oftentimes you'd hit a wall
there's no place you know you're there's
no more information that's available in
existing literature so you've got to
start digging into you know archival
material so uh i had learned pretty
quickly you know what archives around
the country usually had the most stuff
so i would go to those archives and i
would dig like where is this is the
place you got to go to like yeah so
libraries or something yeah so the
archive that i generally used about five
different archives uh the most the best
one was probably uh the national
archives in maryland um
they
uh
they have the most stuff uh
and they have the
it's accessible um
when you start getting to the military
archives that's the army so much the
army archives is actually really a
world-class institution i loved uh going
there that's in carlisle
the marine corps uh archive in quantico
another uh another great
archive the navy yard uh it uh
or the uh the uh naval heritage and
history command archive at the navy yard
that was a bit trickier uh they had uh
for whatever reason i think a lot of it
had to do with the fact that they had an
active shooter there a few years before
so security on the on the base was tight
but they would really it's a very close
held institution so when you went there
uh you know digging through their stuff
uh could be a little complicated you had
to plan around it um
but you'd find stuff you'd find you know
i found uh
letters the pedicore had written and
you've gotta really you've gotta look at
the letter you've gotta read it once you
gotta you know highlight what's
important and you've gotta read it again
and again and figure out you know what
you can learn about him from the letter
the way he talks the way he writes the
way he thinks
when you run into that when you can't
you know squeeze any more information
out of that
uh then you're you're left with finding
the family
and
you know in this case i found pedochords
family uh i tried to find you know at
least a family member for every you know
person that i uh you know focused on in
the book um
had dinner with uh
buck halperin's uh
son last night
still close friends with him
uh but pedigree's family you know some
of these people they don't realize like
how important
their dad or their grandfather was in
this history and they have no idea why
you're calling them and they you know
they you know they would provide photos
they'd provide letters sometimes they
would let you come to their house and
dig through their stuff
but yeah
pedicore was one of those that uh i
didn't expect to find as much as i did
but talking to them i mean you can get
little details out of them i found one
photo of pedicord wearing those boots
and
i i knew that they were uh you know the
boots that uh army cavalry soldiers wore
uh and i i didn't anticipate that there
were boots that he wore you know through
the rest of his career until i ran into
an old scout and raider i was a 96 year
old guy old jim barnes is what they
called him
i was like you know i i sat down to
interview jim barnes and i you know what
do you remember about pedicore and the
first thing that he remembered
were those boots
damn little detail
uh
um
after this here you you detail
you go through some of the details of
operation torch which is up in north
africa the cebu river um
it's
it's a success you know it's a tough
operation um
five of the ten original tuna fish get
the navy cross from that operation and
again i'm skipping through some of that
right now get the book get the book and
read about that freaking operation
because it's epic
um
the origination
and you know we've said this a couple
times but
the origination of everything that goes
on here is is um
you you have to tell talk about the
raiders you have to talk about the
rangers you have to talk about why
why why
what happened to them and why they
didn't become seals
or at least the seal type thing
this is a section here where you start
talking about um well the rangers right
so the premise is you know
that the navy should never have had this
capability
when i started trying to come up with a
title for the book i one my options for
subtitles were like something like the
origin story the navy seals a unit that
should not exist something like that
something is you know provocative like
like that and the reason they shouldn't
exist
uh is because of the army in the marine
corps and the and the cia all of these
uh institutions were better suited for
this mission than the navy was
uh
so in order to you know explain the
question that i you know ask at the
beginning how the navy you know come to
field this you know land focus go
anywhere commando force
the way that's phrased is
you have to understand why these other
institutions didn't uh become that first
why they didn't block the navy from
becoming that and only in understanding
why they didn't become that can you
understand really understand why the
navy did it why the navy felt like it
had to do it
that includes the rangers
going to the book
the officer selected to command the
rangers 31 year old major william
orlando darby born in fort smith
arkansas in 1911
the same gorilla studded year as lord
lovat and russell volkman
darby grew up believing that he was
destined for greatness of average size
and looks his greatness lay below the
surface as it as it is so often with
tragic men a war would be required to
uncover it black-haired blue-eyed
wide-mouthed as a duck darby had a ruddy
face divided into equal parts forehead
and chin
his left cheek bore a mysterious
brilliant red scar not particularly
muscular he nevertheless affected chest
out shoulders back posture in which his
arms seemed always cocked to the rear as
if never more than a moment away from
snapping to attention son of a printer
and a musician the second child between
two sisters he grew up scouting the
arkansas woods and playing the saxophone
while in high school
his older sister died
in texas he married then divorced in
spite of disappointment and tragedy his
attitude remained as it ever had been
good humored and
irrepressible in personality just like
his posture he was direct forceful and
never vacillating
had the military gene not dominated and
given and driven him to a life of
soldiering he would have made a born
salesman
he is the ideal commando leader wrote
colonel vaughn at the end of the course
he possesses the energy keenness and
personality which produces the best out
of those under his command graduated
from west point in 1933 at the apex of
the bell curve ranked 177 out of 346 he
was originally assigned as a field
artillery officer
fast forward a little bit if the ideal
army officer was equal parts confidence
bravery energy and obedience
darby was all these things but perhaps
too much the last more than anything he
believed his men could and should
perform any mission assigned to them
from the most audacious lightning raids
to the most
ignominious rear echelon duties to the
most spectacular seized season hold
operations because of this no one would
be more responsible for proving the
value of the rangers
or for their downfall
so
you go into talking about their first
experience the rangers first combat
experience which was in yep am i saying
that right yeah yep that's i think i
said france 1942
yeah and that
that one
sentence that i give dip
that represents 20 pages of book that i
had to cut out
like i spent
like i said the research is really
seductive and when you find something
that is so
you know what you think is meaningful or
what you think um
you know sort of shows you the direction
that this whole thing is going in you i
mean the the temptation is to really
really focus on it and drag your reader
through this
but you have to remember that you know
you're trying to get the reader
someplace and you don't want to front
load a chapter with 20 pages of battle
and introduce characters in this battle
or of this battle they're really not
going to take you anywhere
god they're all so epic uh speaking of
british commandos jocko's perhaps
inspiration for being a commando himself
you got this quoted i'm just going to
read one quote this is what the rangers
said about the
about the commandos that they went into
dieppe with my god those commandos can
fight remember one ranger after the
battle they'd kneel down or lie down and
fire then stand up grab an apple off a
tree and start firing again
freaking brits
um so you go through that raid you go
through another raid was even more
dramatic victim of a winch that broke
while lowering his landing craft dumping
him his radios and equipment back into
the ocean darby nevertheless scrambled
back aboard his boat then led four
companies plus one chaplain ashore there
despite squelching wet boots he and his
rangers marched uphill for three miles
every man carrying a full load out of
ammunition plus fighting knives bayonets
climbing ropes one stick of dynamite and
two mortar rounds the two unluckiest
also pushed a mule cart
bulging with still more mortar rounds
when the rangers arrived at fort de nord
they found it was surrounded by
concentric circles of barbed wire as
high as eight feet and as deep as 14
with every snip each man's nerves nerves
cinched tighter just as they were about
to reach the last ring a machine gun
barked and drove them to the ground
darby ever the artillery man wasted no
time roy pull up your pull your company
back a few yards then hit him when the
barrage stops lieutenant murray had got
had hardly gotten his men untangled from
the wire when the first rounds thumped
into the battlements thus persuaded the
french defenders abandoned their machine
guns and retreated chased by murray and
his rangers shouting hi-ho silver away
that's fighting against the um
the french the vichy french
yeah fast forward a little go ahead no
i mean the
when you read that and when you uh when
you think about the rangers it just
reinforces everything i said before the
seals should not exist yeah when you
have you know what is clearly a naval
commando force a go anywhere commando
force
as capable as the rangers were in 1942
this is a capability the army
had they created it they were smart
enough to create it and then
they
lost sight of the reasons that they
created it and or actually didn't lose
sight of the reasons the the reasons
that they created it are the reason that
they had the downfall they didn't care
about you know the rangers commando
capability they were more preoccupied
with using the rangers as a way to teach
the rest of the army how to fight we
want to integrate our rangers with
british commandos
because the british commandos were
really the only english-speaking
troops on the planet that knew how to
fight they wanted to
you know george marshall wants to take
that experience and
pass it along to the rest of the u.s
infantry or the the army infantry
and so by the time that the infantry
starts to
you know elevate itself to the uh the
capabilities of the rangers
then divisional commanders start using
the rangers more not uh commandos to go
you know raid a
uh
an artillery position or a command post
they just start pushing them ahead of
the infantry uh almost sort of sort of
like suicidal spearheaders and when you
know when the chapter ends i mean it's
it's just it's so depressing but so
predictable
let's get there
this is a massive mission this is in uh
cisterna
you go through i mean i'm gonna i'm
gonna catch the last little bit of it
you go through the battle you go through
it unfolds i mean there's so many
leadership lessons to learn in here
obviously i talk about leadership all
the time the amount of leadership
lessons that are in this book is
incredible
um
kind of wrapping this up since he'd been
blown off the top of a smoking tank
dobson had somehow made it back to his
men
near the caliph calacaprini house
there while organizing another defensive
perimeter he had taken more shrapnel's
right thigh now lying in a ditch next to
a burning self-propelled gun whose
artillery rounds continued to cook off
around him he passed his command to
captain charles schumstrom a ranger
since the akaneri days and darby's tank
killing comparison compa and darby's
tank killing companion at gala
upon taking command shunstrom an
aggressive as aggressive a soldier as
the us army had ever produced shored up
his position with several companies of
the third battalion and even attempted a
flanking movement to either break free
of the encirclement or believe it or not
take the town
none of it worked
at 10 45 solid communications were
finally established between darby and
shunstrom's radio the care of which was
now in the hands of captain edwards
edward kitchens kitsch to everyone who
knew him who was set up in the first
battalion's makeshift aid station and
whose feet were gradually becoming more
and more encumbered by wounded rangers
at 11 15 darby told kitsch to hold on
and that the 4th battalion was making
slow but steady progress
30 minutes later darby reiterated his
encouragements and even asked kitsch to
put together a rescue party for third
division's reconnaissance company that
reportedly had been captured in his
vicinity
maybe you can break up the thing and
rescue them darby said his suggestion is
tone deaf as his original expectations
operationally employed like infantry
darby's rangers were now dying like them
too
at the calla caprini house alone lay
some 16 dead rangers another 22 wounded
and only five men still fighting barely
three loaded weapons among them
at 12 15 kitsch became so over what
overwrought and weeping that he could no
longer make himself understood
darby asked for another voice and kitch
quit the house altogether preferring to
die outside in battle rather than
trapped inside manning the radio
grasping the receiver now was a hulking
ranger master sergeant robert e holt
from brooklyn new york one of darby's
originals
some of the fellas are giving up colonel
said he halt his voice scratching out of
the speaker box
we're awfully sorry they can't help it
because we're running out of ammunition
but i ain't surrendering
in his farmhouse command post darby
became frantic
don't let the boys give up he pleaded
get the old men together and lamb for it
how many men are still with you
they're coming into the building now e
halt replied gunfire snapping in the
background we're out of ammo but they
won't get us cheap
so long colonel maybe when it's all over
i'll see you again
with a violent wham wham e halt's
transmission will cut out
darby squeezed the handset and steadied
himself
use your head and do what is best you're
there and i'm here unfortunately i can't
help you
it's stung to say the words into the
deadline his fourth battalion still a
mile from cisterna
but whatever happens god bless you god
bless all of you
with the mention of god darby's voice
choked his eyes watered
e halt i leave everything in your hands
tell the men i am with them to the end
after a moment he set down the handset
bracing himself he wrapped his hands
around a telephone receiver and called
general truscott
it apparently was too much for them he
said muffling his emotions replacing the
receiver in its cradle
darby asked his staff to leave the room
as enemy shells beat a steady tattoo
around the house he crumpled into a
chair dropped his head into his arms and
sobbed
several minutes later darby appeared
outside his shoulders straight and his
chin thrust forward defiantly
he was still in command
but in command of what
no one quite knew
i hate hearing that
i uh
this
uh this whole episode is based off of a
couple of sources one of them being
shunstrom's report that he wrote
i want to say three days after the
battle after surviving this thing he was
one of the few uh that escapes
and on a series
on the the radio uh transcription that
they were keeping uh
at darby's
headquarters so
you you can actually see
everything that was said on that radio
and you can read it
and it's
it's horrible
and you know you know i mean no you know
going into it you know where you know
what is going to happen and where
um it doesn't make it easier though
so
despite these um
these legendary heroics like you said i
mean the heroics of the troops are just
undeniable
just after world war ii all six army
ranger battalions were disbanned
and um
you say here specif superficially
modeled on churchill's butcher and bolt
commandos the us army rangers by the
time of their disbandment
looked nothing like them this was in the
end the predictable
result of different parents preoccupied
with the readiness of his front-line
soldiers george marshall had created the
rangers not to perfect the art of
churchill's coastal raids but to serve
his infantry
first by gaining battlefield experience
that could be transferred to the rest of
his troops second by handing them off to
infantry commanders who committed the
rangers to missions with impossible odds
and then either blame them for their
failures or diminish their uniqueness by
using them no differently than regular
infantry
though no one could have guessed the
consequences it was prior it was a
prioritization that produced a lasting
gap in the us military's order of battle
for a unit that specialized in raiding
one that could best be filled by a
branch of service less preoccupied less
preoccupied with this infantry
and there was only one branch
that didn't have infantry
so there you are setting up um
setting up that one branch that doesn't
have any infantry yeah at the time i
mean there's only three branches the air
force doesn't exist yet it's the army
air corps so of all three the army uh
navy and the marine corps navy's it
and you can i mean you can see where
this is going before you even get out of
world war ii you can see
the cycle that's going to it's going to
continue all the way until vietnam
commanders
are going to
identify a gap
they're going to create commandos to
fill that gap
they're going to commit them to action
often to disastrous results and then
they're going to renege on their idea
they're going to pull the rug out from
under these guys and every gap every
time that happens it's often going to
leave uh you know they're the that
unit's commando partners in the lurch
and always that commando partner is the
u.s navy
and the navy is just going to get
more frustrated more frustrated they're
going to continue pushing their uh their
units their special units into that gap
yeah the next the next uh part of the
book is called the opportunity
chapter four subtitled draper kaufman
and the course that cracked the atlantic
wall then laid the first bricks of the
legend of naval special warfare
um
here we go he's the weirdest guy in the
book by far but tall and thin lanky even
with dark hair a narrow face and a chin
that stretched down like a teardrop
draper lawrence kaufman also possessed
poor teeth and spectacles as thick as
sun marine glass
given to bouts of indolence he was
absent-minded a failure in any subject
did not capture his interest and
alarmingly progressive on the issue of
race at least so fought his mother a
shrew on the topic
as a young man kaufman had wanted
nothing more than to attend the naval
academy and command a destroyer as his
father had when poor eyesight threatened
to torpedo his dream he submitted
himself to the doc to doctors orders
however medieval and for one hour a day
held a palm over each open eye
this when his appointing congressman
suddenly died leaving his academy
application in limbo he told no one of
his plan escaped from his connecticut
boarding school got a bunk at the
washington dc ymca and then walked the
halls of congress slipping past
secretaries and performing a rehearsed
sob story until someone anyone gave him
an appointment
once finally accepted he rode crew acted
in school dramas and in cruel
foreshadowing spent 30 days on a prison
ship for sneaking off campus
when he graduated in 1933 a year when
navy pinschers stalked the ranks looking
for any excess ballast to pitch over the
side he was given his diploma and a
physical disqualification from the navy
a steep four-year price to pay for to
achieve the rank of civilian
thus betrayed his childhood dream
kaufman packed his pride shelved any
ideas of glory and settled for an
onshore operations job in the shipping
industry his life suddenly devoted to
endless manifests for onloading and
offloading of cargo
so there's your introduction to an
introduction of draper kaufman i mean
just so many characters and this guy's
definitely one of them gets put on a
six-month assignment to europe while
he's doing that that shipping job while
he's in germany he witnesses adolf
hitler giving speeches
he realizes that this guy's what he
realizes what's coming yeah
um
so fast forward a little bit
he decides he wants to go and serve in
the american voluntary ambulance corps
to be accepted in the american voluntary
ambulance corps a adjunct unit of the
french army one was first required to
submit a down payment of 3 500
to cover living expenses in the cost of
one ambulance in 1940 that was almost
the price of a house even more than
alarming volunteers were bound to follow
orders the french military to a man with
purpose in his boots and adventure in
his guts just the sort of hemingway
hemingway's the french cause had
attracted in the last war no price was
too high
you say actually it was too high it
wasn't
he had to beg borrow and steal to get
this money imagine you you have to come
up with the price of a house to go and
serve in a freaking ambulance corps
where you're gonna get bombed and blown
up
working for the french yeah i mean
we all know the you know draper
kaufman's sort of biography i mean every
not everybody but we get um you know if
you go to buzz you're going to get the
the buds history class or the the seal
history class at some point somebody's
going to mention draper kaufman there
was no there was no buds history there
was no seal history class when i went
through bots
just saying i'm saying there wasn't i
mean it was 1990 so
yeah i know and
that's just gonna make me mad if we talk
about it yeah
no but uh if you come across any sort of
any history book that's been written
draper kaufman's a character
uh and they're gonna hit you know like i
said they're gonna hit the wave tops of
his uh of his biography um you know
before he becomes uh you know the
um a
indispensable uh character in the uh in
the udt's central pacific campaigns
what they're not going to do is they're
not going to put
that biography in context
and when you really dig into it like you
know yes we know he was an ambulance
driver
on the western front in 1940. we don't
know what sacrifice it actually cost him
to put himself in that position
and the reality is so much more like me
i mean you're right i mean
he
you know he
cashed in everything he had you know to
go do something that he believed in like
how many people do you know i don't know
anybody like that today that would you
know
give away your house yeah like
and it was all because he was just
trying to um
trying to do what he thought was right
he was trying to you know serve his
country even though his country wouldn't
take him at the time because he couldn't
see anything
[Music]
it's just
you know every character in this book
they have um
you know
everybody wants to do something in the
book
and most of them don't get to do the
thing that they want
uh but all of us we don't know you know
what legacy we're going to have
and we don't know like
what thing that we don't want to do that
we have to do is going to be the most
important part of our lives and that's
what happens with raper kaufman he
doesn't want to do any of this he
doesn't want to be an ambulance driver
he doesn't want to be a bomb disposal
guy in the blitz he wants to be a naval
officer he wants to be on a destroyer
they won't let him so he does all these
other things to try and live up to what
his dad has done
and he ends up being you know he becomes
a legend yeah because of it
so just to dive into a little bit of
kaufman what he did on may 10 1940
kaufman arrived at his post six miles
beyond
the protection of the maginot forts in
the tsar river value valley in the
northeast shoulder of france where where
the borders come to a point and ju like
a salient into the ravenous mouth of
germany
the same day hitler launched 100
divisions through the ardennes forest
as he
as he had known it would the second war
second world war had begun
and again and again for two unrelenting
weeks draper drove to the front picked
up survivors and returned the inside of
his ambulance slippery with blood the
whole while he sustained himself on bits
of food and the horror of french
cigarettes
the only sleep to be had was taken in
snatches never in a bed and never with
his boots off responding to the
deliberate fire of german mcgunner's
bosch barbarians he called them he and
his fellow ambulance drivers began
draping dark blankets over the side of
their vehicles to cover the giant red
cross emblems by the end of his third
week in combat two ambulances had been
shot out from under him and he had lost
10 pounds
this is what he gave his a house worth
of money to go do
on the afternoon of september 7th 1940 a
thousand german planes attacked london's
and surrounding areas killing 400 men
women and children and wounding 1200
more the next day 412 were killed
wounding nearly double that number for
57 consecutive days days london was hit
had he arrived any earlier who knows
what the royal navy's reaction would
have been to his request as it happened
as it always happened when opportunity
meets courage draper arrived at exactly
the right moment the day draper kaufman
volunteered for the royal navy he
presented himself to the admiralty at
nine o'clock in the morning so he goes
and volunteers to join the navy um
but because of his eyes by five that
afternoon young draper kaufman was a sub
sub-lieutenant in his majesty's navy
the only one hitch once again he was
barred from duty at sea
several weeks into his new career a
german bomb landed just outside the
hotel in which kaufman was bulleted had
it detonated upon impact kaufman's story
would have been buried along with the
hotel another footnote in military
history nothing more as it happened the
bomb hit did not but did not detonate
its only damage being a 30-foot tunnel
gouged into the earth before long an
army bomb disposal team arrived cordoned
off the area and set to work with hand
tools alone the squad pain tank
painstakingly dug a path to the bomb
enlarge the hole and short up the sides
in case of collapse the objective reach
the bomb without disturbing it gently
unscrew the fuse which the inert remains
from the dirt and accompanied by police
and accompanied by police or sirens by
police car sirens and loudspeakers
unexploded bomb coming through transport
the carcass to a nearby cemetery this
usually this method worked in case it
did not the entire bomb disposal team
was killed the next day
kaufman volunteered for bomb disposal
for eight months from september 1940 to
may 1941 hitler waged a war on the
british people more than 40 000
civilians were killed more than a
hundred thousand were injured the
instrument of all this destruction was
the bomb many of these weapons were
defective or or
deranged as in they failed to detonate
upon impact or were timed to detonate
after a bomb disposal team had arrived
so that's what he ends up doing he ends
up doing this bomb disposal duty um
after a while of doing that he decides
he's going to go back to the states once
he's back in the states the japanese
attack
after two years of waiting the united
states was finally at war in a few days
the message a message found kaufman
ordering him to get out to pearl harbor
right now imagine that japanese trickery
extended beyond strategy and into
engineering draper prepared for the
worst
when shown the 500 pound bomb at
schofield barracks he sent everyone else
to cover then examined it sketched it
and telephoned each nail-biting step
back to his controller
it had been dropped too low he
determined landing on its side instead
of its nose what he had visualized
visualized as an old-fashioned oriental
puzzle turned out to be the easiest job
he'd ever had i couldn't have set that
bomb off it if i had a sledgehammer he
said later to those who witnessed his
the bespeckled master pushed past the
line of gawkers to single-handedly
disarm the bomb there were few actions
as deserving of praise
couple headlines dc man takes live [ __ ]
balm apart gets navy cross ran the
headline in the washington post all
florida will rejoice with rear admiral
james l kaufman on being the father of
so worthy of son
so there you go
that's where draper kaufman comes from
um yeah
draper is uh
there's some folks in the um
that uh have spent their lives looking
at uh uh the history of naval special
warfare um and they know more about this
history than than even i do i mean they
you know i specialized over the you know
like i said the period from world war ii
to the period of vietnam they have a a
even fuller account uh than i do
um and one of the things that annoys
them
is that draper kaufman has risen to this
uh sort of you know like i said
legendary status he's you know
considered by many the uh the the father
of america's frogman
he's not
he doesn't uh um he doesn't create the
udt he doesn't create the frogmen uh he
um
he happens to be
uh the pivotal person at multiple uh
points in that history um but he he's
not the uh he's not the godfather like
uh everybody or not like many people
have suggested that he is including his
sister who wrote a you know pretty
decent biography of him
um
but
like i said he is uh he's a
consequential person what's also
interesting about him is that he is
like everybody else in this book is he
is
he's making decisions um
or he he's uh
he's deciding to do everything he does
he's not a um he's not a victim of
history he's not riding a wave like
like a lot of people you know would
suggest we're all sort of doing like the
uh there's a there's a metaphor that
people use to describe the the
transformation of the seal teams and
that's the evolution we've all seen that
uh sort of uh painting at peas where
you've got the you know the the naked
warrior crawling out of the surf and
then you've got the sort of vietnam guy
sort of crouched and uh you know wearing
his tiger stripe fatigues you know all
and and next to the uh the the seal in
iraq or afghanistan wearing the body arm
and everything that they call that
transformation the evolution the
evolution sort of suggests though that
this uh that this transformation was one
inevitable
uh and that uh it didn't uh require uh
the um
uh
the intent
uh that all of these uh folks who have
uh this consequential role in our
history
had and they they clearly had intent i
mean when draper's going through his
history
or his biography
he's deciding uh that he's going to go
serve in the french army and when the
the germans send him home after he's
released from the pow camp uh and they
you know make him sign this document
that he's going to go back to the states
and he'll never take up arms against the
german empire again
he
intentionally decides that he's not
going to do that he's going to go join
the british navy and he's going to
continue he continually does this
and just like everybody in the book they
are
they're not victims
they're
each of these characters they all have
agency and they all decide uh that
they're going to do these things for
whatever reason mostly it's uh the
decision that they arrive at is to
satisfy what they um
have decided is uh
their version of relevance there's a
spot where you say basically um
draper kaufman
is not
really the godfather that people
some people give him credit for of the
frog man but
such a consequential guy he is a
consequential guy and you're right he's
not the he's not the
the father of america's frogman kelly
turner is that kelly turner creates the
udts nobody would have done it if it
wasn't for kelly turner he wants the
udts because the marine corps uh
at every step they uh they frustrate his
plans to use reconnaissance troops and
kelly turner he's um
uh
kelly turner wants to control everything
in his orbit
and so he creates the udts to do just
that he doesn't the the demolition is
sort of secondary he wants a
reconnaissance force that he owns uh and
draper just happens to be the vehicle
for for kelly turner's um
uh you know once
we pick we do pick up with um
with draper kaufman though you say as
such who better to start the navy's
underwater demolition course in the
second world war than the men who'd seen
the most of it the man who'd seen the
most of it a sailor for whom no barrier
ever held and who was about to squeeze
his biography into a syllabus like none
that had ever existed
to create the type of amphibious
engineer that he envisioned envisioned
kaufman needed elbow room like pedicore
before him he found his elbows had ample
space in fort pierce florida
to create such a unit he would require
students with
in his words both temperamental
stability and individual initiative to
that end kaufman insisted that
candidates be subjected to very heavy
physical training very heavy he
emphasized again as he knew from his own
career first in france then in the blitz
this type of experience would show
students that they could push beyond
their physical limits doing without
sleep and food and warmth and still
function without their arms falling off
more important training of such
intensity would create its in its
students a sense of purpose and unity
like nothing except actual war
fast forward a little bit
short on time
eager to screen out the obvious people
that would not make it physically and
long on his desire to simulate an
experience that
was as close to war as possible
kaufman decided that all three problems
could be solved by the same solution
one week of misery
never reluctant to ask for help he
walked south along tent row until he
came to the section reserved for the
scouts and raiders there still six
months away from being transferred
pedicured
listened to kaufman's proposal he had
never been asked to compress the scouts
and raiders eight week physical train
conditioning course into one block of
uninterrupted training
certainly men could be pushed indeed
nearly broken but what kaufman had asked
to do was another matter in the end
pedicore agreed what else could he do
this was kaufman the seas parted at his
arrival
what pedicore did not know no one did
was that he was about to help create
the set the sacramental cup from which
from which nearly all future naval
commandos would drink
you were wet chaffed with sand just
completely miserable
remembered frank kane years later in the
daytime men melted under the sun at
night they shook so hard from the wet
and cold that their hip flexors swelled
and cramped their teeth chattered like
jackhammers shouldering boats sloshing
with water they marched for miles and
sand and dunes that collapsed beneath
every step
sodden fatigues adhered to the grit and
sand
turning armpits thighs and scrotums into
raw meat
if any instructor detected a student on
the stealth and concealment problem as
he wormed his
his chafed and dripping body to the
plantation house the man was punished by
being sent to sit inside where swarms of
mosquitoes feasted on his misery
in addition to simple surf drills rubber
boat training included hours of paddling
while harassed by the nearby air
squadrons f4 pilots who would try to
nail the floating rafts with sacks of
flower bombs
jetty landings and night portages were
attuned by based ambulances and
performed over boulders as broad as
dinner tables the endless serve smashing
the panels and men against the rocks
intended to simulate the long drain of
campaign march before battle this
seemingly endless harassment ultimately
culminated in a day-long mock skirmish
known as the extended order problem or
to the students so solid day
beginning before dawn students raced off
the ramps of their landing craft just as
the beach erupted in thundering sheets
of flame
for a whole day instructors armed with
charges unleashed a torrent of exploding
columns of water and showers of mud and
debris
the student's belly crawled on throbbing
knees and elbows into hip deep mud
swamps and surf as the explosions chased
them from cover and foxholes
until kaufman's regime no navy unit had
been subjected to training course whose
essence so closely resembled that of
real war
the frantic harassment the inescapable
cold the relentless exhaustion
not only did it prepare men for what was
to come
it set them apart from everyone else in
the navy
even in the early classes as many as
half the men who started did not
complete the week
that was entirely the point modeling his
project on the culture of the core franc
kauffman had set out to forge both an
esprit de corps and the reputation that
always accompanies it exclusivity
if you haven't been through it he would
later say you're not a demolitioneer
in august 1943 kaufman volunteered for
his own program at 32 years old with
eyesight not good enough to qualify for
his own demolition standards
he was hardly an ideal candidate
i think i have never seen a man struggle
so desperately warnock said after
witnessing kaufman's performance the
moment he finished his 10 mile beach run
he passed out during the ocean swim
warnock thought he would drown
we all knew he wasn't a great athlete
said frank kane and we thought hell if
he can make it we can too
throughout the training kaufman listed
but never sank alternately encouraging
and bullying his boat crew from start to
finish as one remembered with his bloody
battle cry of core frank
when men showed signs of cracking during
another bone trilling dip in the ocean
kaufman turned it into a joke annoyingly
repeating the same mocking phrase the
water he boomed in his strong
mid-atlantic accent is never cold
the monday after kaufman completed this
week he was ordered to report to captain
clarence goldbergson
the base commander of fort pierce
swollen from head to foot with fingers
like sausages ready to burst he crawled
out of bed and staggered into the
commander's office
what's this i hear about 40 percent of
your classes either being in the sick
bay or quitting the captain bark i don't
think you have any idea what you're
putting these men through draper
i do kaufman responded it was
hell when kaufman's trainees completed
hell week the name
his week of miserably misery inevitably
took on their demolitions training
program progressed to its next phase two
weeks of explosives two week of
reconnaissance and three weeks of
practical exercises
so there you go
freaking hell week
yeah created by
i mean we we look around i mean
how many team guys do you know that
would fit his bill today
i mean
we kind of think that we sort of created
ourselves
i mean we have a lot of people that
sort of came together to create this
program and they're not they don't look
like us i mean they were sailors uh
ship fleet sailors i mean that put this
thing together and somebody who's you
know the most unlikely uh person i mean
draper kaufman is not what you would
think of as a modern day seal or modern
day frogman in fact you don't want to be
he just i mean he's
he sort of continues to do the thing
that he doesn't really want to do
because that's the right thing that he
you know the it's the thing that's going
to accomplish the mission that he's been
given which is to demolish hitler's
atlantic wall he doesn't know how else
to do it so he you know he squeezes
every drop of his biography into this
curriculum
uh
fast forward a little bit actually fast
forward a pretty good chunk going into
d-day
and again your your
your detail and the the research that
you did to get here is just it's
unbelievable to read
with terrified soldiers frozen in place
neither advancing or retreating freeman
and kaylee
kihely sprinted between posts yelling
obscenities and kicking the infantry men
away once clear freeman gave the signal
tossed a purple smoke grenade and petty
officer bass pulled the fuse fire in the
hole at 6 55
only 22 minutes after the landing the
whole area exploded in a roar that
drowned out the battle's den shooting
skyward a mixture
of water smoke wood sand and steel high
into the air the defender's response was
vicious as soon as the smoke and debris
settled the fire from the hills became
unbearable as mingled or if the georgian
with a hole in his leg crawled hand over
hand to the sea wall and safety around
slammed through his helmet into his
forehead killing him instantly
with the obstacles blown and the beach
cover gone petty officer bass a former
seabee from durham north carolina
resisted the urge to run and instead
found seaman farrell alone still
writhing from the hole in his knee and
with a fresh wound to his right eye bass
bent down to cradle the boy to cover him
and as he did a bullet tore through his
back entering just to the right of his
spine and blowing a hole out his right
shoulder sergeant murphy one of the
army's naval augmentees found them both
and dragged them to the sea wall wounded
himself and with nearly everyone in his
crew either shot or dead freeman was
unstoppable blasting obstacles clearing
out infantrymen before his charges blew
helping his wounded to cover
though they had been cut to shreds gap
assault team one had completed its
mission their 50-yard
gap was clear
and that's just one
little uh
chunk of the detail that you give on all
these heroic acts that are going on by
fast forward by morning by morning's ed
with the help of hall's destroyers the
gap assault teams had partially cleared
five of their 16 target sections along
omaha beach by nightfall the total was
10. for the ncdus an accomplishment that
came at a cost prematurely estimated at
two dozen dead at least that many
wounded and 15 more missing these last
had either been blown clear of their
landing vessels and drowned or in the
words of one rider had run off to fight
with the army in fact some had done just
that or at least abandoned their section
of beach
as a handful of planters had expected
the most difficult aspect of rommel's
atlantic wall had been the beach and the
underwater obstacles a problem that had
been overcome only because of the navy's
commitment
first in identifying the issue next in
commissioning kaufman to solve it then
in sharing those lessons with the army's
combat engineers ultimately however the
navy's greatest contribution had come
from the ncdus themselves in addition to
the presidential unit citation admiral
hall had gone on to recognize the
demolitioners by recommending them
a trunk full of individual awards
individual awards including six navy
crosses
one of which went to chief petty officer
bill freeman
i kicked myself ever since that i had
didn't recommend him for a medal of
honor hall said later i never heard of
anybody who did a greater job than that
fellow did
responsible for getting the army past
the underwater obstacles on omaha beach
the ncdu's achievement was in the end
made possible only by their training at
fort pierce there they had learned not
only the technical skills of underwater
demolition the explosives the pole fuses
the minimum safe distances but also as
kaufman had insisted the ability to push
past the limits of normal human
endurance to withstand cold hunger raw
skin exhaustion even the chaos of combat
the kind of fortitude that made winning
wars possible only our vigorous training
held us together one survivor said
afterward but what about but what about
after that
with the collapse of the atlantic wall
the mission of the ncdus had been
accomplished and therefore no unit in
the u s military was in greater threat
of disbandment
or at least would have been had it not
been for one final hang-up the navy's
planners were loath to disband a unit
that had just performed so effectively
after all the war was far from over
and there was no shortage of needs for
sailors so conditioned to the combat
that lay ahead
boom
yeah it's uh
i mean i don't know about you but nobody
ever connected uh hell week or the
reason for hell week to omaha beach but
i don't think
that we would have that crucible today
if it wasn't for that
it justified everything that kaufman did
um
i mean we
later in the war you see
lots of people get pulled over to the
udt
whether they're seabees or marines or
even soldiers in some instances uh and
those you know
they do they don't necessarily go
through hell week if it had not been for
that experience
uh it's likely that we would not have
this
uh
like that that crucible and without that
crucible what would the seal teams be
i mean there'd be another commando for
us but would they be
uh everything that we are today i mean
that's the defining moment of training
right yeah yeah well you called it the
sacramental cup
it is the sacrament i mean yeah we all
have these uh i mean
uh
there's institutions all around us
whether the institutions are the us
constitution or they're uh whatever uh
your catholicism i mean that your faith
has these little institutions built into
it and you know if you're going to take
the catechism uh there's all these
sacraments that you've got to do and
what's more uh what's a bigger sacrament
and you know the becoming of a seal than
uh than hell week
yeah
not one
um
you get into next uh tarawa
and what happens at tarawa which is a
total nightmare um
i don't know if you had the chance we we
had a guy um dean lad that was on this
podcast and he was a marine corps wow i
think he was a
i think it was a first lieutenant by
that time wow uh that did a bunch of
islands including tarawa got gut shot
tarawa 800 yarders from the beach two
marines disobeyed orders to leave him
and move forward and dragged him back to
a boat he survived ended up going back
but um yeah you detail what happened
there how bad it was
and basically if you don't know anyone
that doesn't know the
the marine corps hit reefs on the way in
and the boats got hung up and so the
guys had to get out and walk
with no protection whatsoever
through the ocean 800 it was around 800
yards to get to the beach where there
was
it wasn't
once they got to the beach it was hell
as well
so and we've always known that tarawa is
the moment that you know the the need
for udts is identified we don't exactly
know the reason though i mean because
the marine corps they come up with the
the solution or what they perceive to be
the solution before the taro battle even
commences and that like i described is
the the landing vehicle tractor the lvt
it's a technical problem they have a
technical solution for it
the problem with that is turner
doesn't like their solution uh kelly
turner uh sees the cancer or sees the
the coral as a cancer it it's gonna
complicate everything uh as far as all
the the rest of the campaigns ahead of
him he doesn't want to deal with us he
wants to he he wants that coral out so
he can get his higgins boats to the
beach and the only way to do that is to
find him
yeah and what's interesting too is
after tarawa
the marine corps solution was
you know like you said it was just more
yeah more yeah just okay so we're going
to lose x percentage of boats on the way
and cool more we're going to lose this
many ltvs on the land cool more bring us
more that was their answer and turner
was saying hey actually not a good
answer let's let's figure out how to
solve this problem yeah churchill's
quote you know we've we've run out of
money now it's time to think i mean it
you could just you could say you know
just as uh just as much when it comes to
logistics
there i mean there's nothing that
compares with the us military's
logistics and manufacturing might going
into this but we still have limits you
can't these lvts they take up a ton of
space on all the ships that the navy's
going to use to transport them the the
higgins boats they they're easier to
carry they're faster in the water
you can time everything from naval
gunfire support to aircraft coming in to
support the landings if you have a
faster vehicle to get them from the
ships to the shores
and that's what turner wants he wants to
be able to get his ships as quickly to
the beach as possible it's the safest
way uh it's the easiest to get
everything there and the only way to do
that is to find the coral and get rid of
it
we start training now but under turner's
direction we start training we're
training in hawaii now
in may a fresh batch of ncdu recruits
arrived in maui per the direction of
kohler and kaufman the men were told to
abandon the bulk of their gear their
green fatigues their boots their maywest
life jackets even their helmets and
sidearms and slip into a
pair of black maui swim trunks and dive
masks
their rough rubber edges sanded down to
prevent them from biting into their face
what followed were nine seemingly
endless days of training on how to
systematically map an underwater
landscape and blow it up
rocks coral night swimming blast no rest
no sleep suicide stuff one trainee
remembered
for fewer for no fewer than six hours a
day recruits lived in the water
perfecting their strokes until they
could swim a mile before breakfast their
only day off was monday when possible
seeing that this was the first time many
of them had handled explosive fused or
tied prime recorded into a trunk line
accidents were routine fingers blown
clear off or hanging by bloody shreds of
skin asked how long he could swim
underwater with a hundred pounds of
powder recruit kenorik replied with a
hundred pounds of powder i could
probably stay under forever
so this is i highlighted that port
because this is a point now where we're
starting to see
you know the id of the naked warrior
they're getting rid of all their gear
they're just wearing trunks
um
saipan
is where we get this recon
[Music]
like a like a legit recon going on the
closer his swimmers got to the beach the
more nervous kaufman became at 100 yards
he tried to turn them around but most of
them kept going at 50 yards some began
to pivot back but some didn't closing to
within 30 yards of the shore and 40
yards of the guns
so close that they
ceased swimming and dug their toes of
their sneakers into the sand pulling
themselves along with their gloved hands
when that last line finally did run out
of water each man backed off slightly
turned left then sidestroked along the
beach for 25 yards edging his mask out
of the water with every breath breath
careful to remember the locations of any
gun positions under circumstances not an
easy thing to forget
on the swim back each man ignored his
exhaustion and worsening leg cramps and
stayed as close as possible to the
bottom
when the they neared the reef kaufman
re-boarded his mattress and offered a
nearby swimmer a toe get that damn thing
out of here this is you go over this
earlier all the the little rafts that
they had were getting shot up on the
other side of the now surf slammed reef
each swimmer waited for pickup when the
landing craft arrived the coxswains took
turns motoring each man
and either drop
drop them a jacob's ladder or reversed
engines until he could grab hold and
pull himself up
throughout this cumbersome boarding a
period packed with vociferous cursing
said one survivor every man aboard fully
expected a mortar round to drop square
into the boat
as soon as the last man was loaded
kaufman tallied his numbers and realized
that in addition to the officer killed
on the air mattress two of his swimmers
were still missing pulled in separate
directions by his instinct to rescue his
and his orders to rush back to the fleet
kaufman looked around at his blue tinge
to black striped men and chose the more
painful option with the fleet waiting
for his information kaufman ordered his
boats back to the apd's
when the men of udt7 arrived back at the
humphreys they discovered something
remarkable though several men had been
wounded
some with serious internal injuries from
the mortar blast not a single one of
their swimmers had been lost in fact the
only men that had been killed have been
the ones who had remained on the lcpr's
as they had waited for swimmers to
return kaufman's udt5 swimmers had been
slightly left less fortunate with one
killed several more wounded and two
still missing but it was nothing
compared to the bloodbath that occurred
just one week before at normandy
so this is another methodology
of executing these things and it's sort
of a metaphor for you know what actually
happened the entire history so the you
know the navy
uh
intentionally creates all of these units
they create ncdus they create
udts that create the scouts and readers
all these units are created for a
specific purpose they're committed to
action for a specific reason
but
once the navy creates these things the
navy can't necessarily predict how far
the individuals that are that belong to
these institutions are going to push
them they're going to push those
envelopes so kaufman you know when he's
driving his men toward the beach or he's
pushing his men to swim he also is
trying to stop them
he's trying to stop them 50 yards from
sure they won't they keep going 25 yards
so you know the the seal teams are
created by the navy they're created by
the navy for the navy but the you know
you can sort of see it just in that
moment um
the seal teams become so much more
because of the seals themselves so the
seals don't create it we don't we're not
responsible for our own institutions we
think we are but we're not
but we are responsible for what that
institution ultimately became
yeah you know there's an interesting
time that you make in the book and i
don't remember if it's in my notes to
carrots i'll just mention it now
um
the navy
just by nature of being disaggregated
and being spread apart especially back
in the day
there was decentralized command unlike
really unlike any other organization
absolutely and that that spirit of
decentralized command of like hey you go
and you make you take the fight to the
enemy
you get in this ship or you get in this
submarine you go overseas and you take
the fight to the enemy that's you have
mission type orders right and that's
that's the way the navy has had to exist
back in the day and that
vein
and that that dna remains and that's why
you get these guys that are very
proactive and
will will will be default aggressive out
there on the battlefield that's that's
exactly right default aggressive
latitude only works
if
your default uh orientation or uh
default setting is aggression
and if you read
any uh like naval history book during
like uh you know the napoleonic wars or
if you read you know the patrick o'brien
master and commander series like you're
you're never you know connected to your
chain of command whereas the army uh
always is always this yeah so that uh
you know as technology has improved or
as technology has gotten better to
connect commanders to their troops in
the field that chain of command has only
thickened whereas in the navy
i mean we have all this history behind
us or the navy has all this history
behind it of latitude of mission type
orders of relying on the aggressiveness
of the individual commander
you just have to trust your guys
but you have to be specific about what
you want oh for sure so otherwise you
get rogue
exactly uh you do talk about what the
udts brought back from that and what
they brought back was good information
good intel that they could then form and
to uh make a better battle plan the
invasion of sidepan goes smoother um
fast forward a little bit by the fall of
1944 the navy's underwater demolition
teams were the most indispensable of all
u.s military's special operations units
a facet directly attributed to the
central pacific planners who would no
longer go anywhere without their
reconnaissance reports
the udts were an essential part of our
amphibious organization for the
remainder of the war wrote turner on the
last day of combat on tinian it is it is
questionable if we could have made our
landings except after the great losses
except after great losses if we had not
had these teams to prepare the way
this assessment was immediately echoed
by admiral connolly who concluded his
invasion in guam by declaring that
without udt's discovery
and demolition of some 640 obstacles
along 3 000 yards of beaches including
the nearly car sized coconut log cribs
filled with loose coral the landings
quote would could not have been made
there in spite of orders forbidding them
to do so three demolition swimmers
including gunner's first mate
gunner's first mate gunners mate first
class
henry l green
had grown so convinced of the udt's
worth that they had planted a white
butcher block-sized sign at the water's
edge with the following message u.s
marine welcome to the uso greetings from
udt4
hearing this admiral connolly had
summoned the team's commander to his
state room in order to hand him a starch
counseling
but instead had neutralized his own
admonitions
by stopping the young officer at the
door declaring wait till i tell turnell
turner he'll have those marine generals
eating crow
um
it's so childish but yeah it's so
childish but that's i mean that's what
it is i mean how many times have you in
your service you you know interacted
with you know
you know a sister service and i mean the
rivalry exists yeah like it's a you know
it's a brotherhood you know on the
battlefield but still we're you know
always chasing our institutional
prerogatives or trying to you know push
the boundaries of uh uh you know our
institutional authority yeah and what's
interesting is when you get into the
senior ranks there becomes real
there's a real tension between the
services and the and the amount of money
that they get right and and it becomes a
real thing
um
but yeah
you say here to recognize their
contribution for taking of the marion
marianas turner showered the udts with
awards more than 60 silver stars 300
bronze stars reported the largest mass
recommendation for sailors and marines
in the war up to that point given the
importance of the job connolly would
have pinned navy crosses on
on the commanding officers of udt 3 and
4 but ended in the end settled for
silver stars each of them presented by
none other than admiral kaufman drape
draper's father as for draper himself
rumors circulated about his nomination
for the medal of honor an accolade his
father chairman of the awards board in
the pacific lobbied against for fear of
the medals association with recklessness
in the end draper received a navy cross
his second pinned on by his father with
a comment that allowed the photographer
to catch the serious young man in a
laugh
thank the lord you found a clean short
yeah that's a relationship i could have
spent a lot more time on yeah i mean
he's
you know draper's dad is out there you
know in the fleet he's
he's a commodore himself and uh
you know
he knows exactly the risks that his son
is taking and he does nothing uh during
the entire war uh to either
uh convince turner uh
you know to have the udt take less risk
he just
he's as uh
you know i i i don't know
uh as a father and i know you're a
father too like i don't know that i'd be
able to
to keep myself uh disciplined enough to
to not interfere
you'd give him orders to uh the
washington dc uh admin spot
yeah i just don't know how whatever that
impulse uh you know that those guys had
i i don't know that it exists today but
either that you'd make him a freaking
boat crew leader in beauty for just
freaking ready to get something
uh this is just you you jump into this
next part chapter six the contest for
the guerrilla war in china and the
organization that had no damn business
fighting in it the us navy's army of
sailors this is just freaking buck wild
this whole section
i mean you get this guy born milton e
roberts in 1900 in jerome arizona miles
spent his first years
in a mountainside mining hub
called by the new york sun in 1903 the
wickedest town in the west
he was only a child he was the only
child of a lumber cutter who was nearly
30 years older than his mother before
miles was even eight his father was dead
which was something of a blessing as it
had given given his mother an
opportunity to move and remarry then in
seattle his stepfather miles had
received from his stepfather miles had
received the last name he would live
with but not much else at 14 miles ran
away from home and you just set up this
background with this guy he enlists in
the navy he ends up doing taking some
tests to get into the in ireland to get
into the naval academy he gets in
goes to the naval academy
um
gets and then he gets deployed to china
for a five-year tour
ends up
um you know doing operations in the
yangtze river
this is the warlord period he learns
about leadership diplomacy geography
small boat handling how to shoot his way
out of a hold up
unlike most westerners
picks up various coastal dialects so
this dude speaking freaking chinese or
mandarin or whatever
um
he's brilliant i mean i there's nobody
i mean like i say you know i mean we got
our history not just from you know
frogmen we got it from you know just
fleet sailors and this is i mean it's
crazy do you ever see the movie sand
pebbles yeah
this is sand pebbles yeah this is santa
so sam bubbles go watch it if you
haven't seen it i know you haven't seen
it echo charles because it's a classic
it's an actual good movie
there's no there's not many like cgi
explosions in it but yeah this is sam
pebbles all day we had the movie sand
pebbles on one of my ark deployments
this is back before internet or anything
so we just had videotapes we would watch
sand pebbles over and over again um and
that's what this guy is doing he's in
so he ends up running these freaking
gorillas in china yeah which is nuts
um he's
i mean
nobody knows about him today like he's
he's completely forgotten to history but
i mean he's every bit as consequential
at least as far as uh the navy's uh
journey from uh
you know the ocean to to the land as you
know say somebody like lawrence of
arabia he doesn't have the the style of
somebody like that which is probably you
know part of the reason that he's
forgotten and you know his book a
different kind of war is you know it's
it's not you know seven pillars of
wisdom
but um you know
he he wrote that thing when he had been
diagnosed with uh
with prostate cancer so he was racing
against the clock to to try and get this
recorded and he was you know he knew he
only had maybe a year uh to live and
he's you know drafting this thing he's
typing up little sections of it uh his
wife um
is is uh cutting these sections out to
reorder them and he's she's putting
these things together with scotch tape
i actually found that record
in the the national archives it still
exists so he talks about
his his wife wrote a the forward to the
book to say you know how this was done
how it was cut re-taped together and
everything like that and then to see
that to find that in the national
archives to hold you know these re-taped
together pages
was pretty incredible but you know like
i said this guy
he is the navy's version of lawrence of
arabia he's the it's freaking crazy yeah
insane
um
and he's a flag officer yeah and he's
involving himself the entire war in
these little mini skirmishes and
ambushes it's i mean he he's almost uh
killed three times just by assassins
yeah it's nuts it's a freaking crazy
story and he loses his mind in the
process yeah yeah oh you say this along
with his promotion admiral king elevated
uh seiko which is the sino-american
cooperation organization this is this
group that they got running all over
china to naval group china an act that
likewise elevated each camp to a formal
and they got all these camps they got
these camps set up he's running this
network of camps
um
uh
an act that likewise elevated each camp
to a formal naval unit and invested
miles with the authority of a group
commander increasing his roles to 600
officers and two 2 400 enlisted men
about 300 more than allotted to a world
war ii battleship and a commitment by
the navy that was further augmented by
various numbers of marines coast
guardsmen and radio operators to supply
all these men's
miles received two planes their engines
rarely idle to which ferry loads from
chung king to the various camps the gas
alone for these planes gobbled up as
much as half of miles monthly tonnage
allotment over the hump but for the
first time in the war sacko camps began
began receiving at least a portion of
what they deserved so this guy is
running a freaking crazy guerrilla war
he's running an army he's a he's a naval
commander who's running an army like uh
like we talked about earlier he's
running
he has no communication with these units
for the most part so he's he's he's
getting these commanders mostly marines
uh that are that are coming to him he's
giving them a spine of sailors to go
work with and then this marine commander
and these navy sailors are trucking
sometimes three months at a time to get
to their station in china they set up a
camp they start training chinese
gorillas and then they commit them to
action
and because he has no communication with
him he has to rely on the aggressiveness
of each of these uh leaders in some
cases it works out in some cases it
doesn't so really all he's doing at this
point is just managing his his talent
pool and assessing whether or not
they're sending back you know aggressive
enough reports about the operations that
they're undertaking uh
anyway
yeah you you cover it i mean it's just
it's incred it's an incredible story
again
there's some books in its own right ten
books like and and the thing that like
was i was blown away with and i i focus
my uh attention of this chapter on camp
six because camp six is really the only
unit uh in saco that is run by a member
of naval special warfare every every
other camp
except in rare instances is run by a
marine so the the legacy of those camps
is you know
uh you know understandably you know a
feather in the marine corps cap they
should be
nothing but you know impressed with the
legacy of the the marine corps led units
but
uh admiral king towards the uh towards
the tail end of this period you know
they're running out of marine's descent
and not only that but the scouts and
raider program is going away
admiral king doesn't want to go away he
wants to send uh you know sort of
quasi-marine sailors to backfill the
marine commitment to saco so he
repurposes the scouts in raiders school
turns it into the amphibious router
school and is trying to get as many uh
marine type sailors into saco as
possible
to justify this course so we don't have
to get rid of this course after the end
of world war ii uh and camp six uh
becomes sort of the repository of all of
that experience buck halperin who you
mentioned at the beginning of the book
the uh the jewish uh uh notre dame
quarterback he gets sent there uh phil
buckley
comes comes west and starts reading
leading reconnaissance and raiding
operations
but yeah camp six is the um
camp six is the first uh instance of
naval special warfare really going
ashore and they do everything they do
raids they do
ship attacks
by the end of the war
halpern is literally leading from the
saddle
on a horse and pushing his gorillas into
action it's incredible yeah yeah it's
it's freaking it's just a great story
and again it it
you know um
i've often said that
you know when i got in the teams i don't
know when you got this still so was
there was no doctrine when you got in
the teams there was no doctrine when i
got in the teams you couldn't if you
wanted to know how to do
uh uh an assault on a target
you you couldn't look it up someone had
to tell you your platoon chief or your
lpo was going to teach you how to do it
it wasn't written down anywhere whereas
the army and the marine corps you can
look at exactly how to do a target
assault it tells you step by step what
to do so we don't have any doctrine we
have more now
but that's one of
one of our biggest weaknesses is that we
don't have any doctrine
one of our biggest strengths is that we
don't have any doctrine and and that's
why you get a freaking guy that's like
oh cool what we're going to do we're
getting under horseback raids that's
what's happening cool let's figure out
how to do it and and again that
decentralized command the default
aggressive attitude
that's that's in that's got to be that's
the dna of the seal teams
and it's rooted back to camp six
camp six
nothing like it
fast forward
the end of the war should have been the
happiest day of my life wrote miles
afterward tasked with an impossible
mission and yoked to impossible partners
he had nevertheless achieved something
greater than ever been asked of him a
navy run gorilla army and intelligence
infrastructure that had stretched from
indochina to the gobi desert assisted by
marines his sailors had trained as many
as a hundred thousand chinese guerrillas
rescued airmen and missionaries blasted
open japanese tanks blown up some 158
bridges derailed some 66 japanese trains
sunk 35 japanese ships raided
uncountable japanese camps and led at
least one cavalry charge on camels
best estimates at the time placed the
number of sacko inflicted casualties at
around 2 26 717 killed 8 702 wounded 600
346 captured of the roughly 2 500
americans who served in seiko five were
killed that's amazing that's amazing
that's amazing and this isn't even con
considering the strategic impact of
soccer because you know they're tying
down a million japanese troops the
entire time yeah
troops that could be fighting on all
those islands right the marines
for sure but they can't a million i mean
there's you know when you think there's
30 or 40 000 japanese on these islands
when most of these islands somewhere
around that number you know if you have
an extra million soldiers to throw into
that mix
as was true of every successful general
in history mile's success had come at
the price of his sleep his health his
family's happiness and even his sanity
for his sacrifices he had been keep not
with praise and press releases but with
troubles bureaucracy and overweening
scrutiny in the end
seiko along with the navy's guerrilla
warfare effort received
a reward as glamorous as an obituary
as miles bitterly concluded the month
that followed the surrender of japan was
the worst
through which i lived
um
yeah after hosting a dinner for many of
his seiko officers this is after the war
this is right after the war miles began
a rambling seemingly endless lecture on
what the atomic bomb would mean for the
u.s navy's future as men awkwardly
drifted out of the room miles continued
unaware when every man had left and when
the lights had been turned off after the
camp doctor confined him to a stateroom
miles jumped from the window and took
off sprinting through a rice paddy
chased by a group of american advisers
and chinese guerrillas he escaped passed
them all and stole a jeep as he rattled
past his pursuers he was heard muttering
over and over i must get to the drill
field
block the road god damn it that's an
order he shouted shouted the camp's
doctor to the driver of a 6x6 truck when
the jeep reached the roadblock miles
jumped out and ordered the truck driver
to move the doctor countermanded the
order and told miles to return to his
quarters whereupon miles accused
everyone of lying to him
you're on the sick list the doctor
finally managed what are you saying
doctor i'm all right i don't think you
are admiral the doctor replied nervously
and
and have to officially inform you that
you are on the sick list and have been
relieved of your command
as the words drilled into miles delusion
the doctor could feel him shaking like a
leaf finally miles relented aye aye
doctor
he hopped back into the jeep returned to
his quarters next morning is placed
under house arrest and his razor
confiscated in washington
metzel met mrs billy miles and infirmed
her
that her husband had a complete mental
breakdown and that they could only hope
he had not suffered permanent brain
damage
no
it broke him i mean he
you know he he literally left everything
in china uh when he comes back it takes
months and months before he regains his
sanity but
he uh
uh
and you know
this whole theater of warfare was i mean
but and it's uh
the just dealing with the chinese on a
daily basis i mean
so many uh other people have tried uh
joe stillwell tries to deal with chiang
kai-shek he i mean he's frustrated his
entire war he leaves not in disgrace but
at least in in massive frustration
uh
wedemeyer has the same uh headaches with
the chinese but what stillwell and
wedomir don't have to deal with is
an oppressive
the oppressive army scrutiny that when
the army gets there i mean they see
china as clearly
you know their area of operations
and it is i mean there you can't argue
with it i mean it's it's
the land i mean just like if the army
decided that they were going to uh seize
control the south china sea the navy
would certainly have something to say
about it but when they get there you
know the navy has this infrastructure in
place and they don't know what to do
with it
so they try to
you know
progressively take control of
miles organization
and
in the end
miles loses out the army takes control
of it uh and the only thing that stops
them from really seizing control is all
of the trouble that miles has had which
is geography they can't see control of
this thing miles maintains his command
over his organization for the remainder
of the war
so the problem is the solution yeah yeah
yeah that's that's it um i got to
mention this this section here at the
time of the japanese surrender
rudy bosch a 17 year old volunteer with
the amphibious rogers looked up from the
middle of the training exercise in the
swamps near lake okeechobee
to hear the class instructor now stop
what you're doing the war is over
told to return to fort pierce bosh and
his classmates were then given a single
final order tear it down what followed
was the sacking of three years worth of
construction mess halls classrooms
offices ranges towers before a backdrop
of flaming white tents tents that had
once proudly lined the roads sheltering
the nearly every that nearly every
special group in the u.s military from
the rangers to the udts the rogers who
had not gotten a crack at china took out
their frustrations by demolishing
everything with their bare hands by the
end of the week the only thing that
suggested the past experience of a naval
base was the pool
last to go were the men themselves
that's it war is over
and with the the rogers too and uh yeah
we didn't even talk
give us a quick brief on the rogers well
the rogers are the uh the sort of the
natural uh culmination of the scouts and
raider program so the scouts and raiders
uh they're the uh
the name sort of doesn't make sense i
mean the
the scouts and raiders seemed like they
would be you know reconnaissance troops
and commandos they really weren't scouts
and raiders are a joint unit created at
the very beginning of the war it's an
army navy unit
the the idea is we need army scout boat
officers to
take army beach marking troops ashore so
the army can
you know signal the landing fleet signal
the landing craft so troops can get into
the right beaches
this is what they do in north africa
uh the problem is after north africa the
army starts to lose interest in this and
and they're
they they they stop creating uh their
portion of the scouts and raiders
because there's they have they have
enough you know beach marking troops for
the remainder of the war so they
basically leave the uh the entire
schoolhouse in the hands of the navy
which you know now the navy has all this
curriculum and they have no prohibition
on what the navy's portion of the scouts
and raider program can do so
naturally the navy starts you know
taking not just the the transportation
side of the mission but they take the
the entire beach marking side of the
mission so
uh they have troops that are quasi
you know commandos that are trained to
do beach marking uh but you know at this
point in the war um or in 1945
uh when
sacco has been created
they realize that they can use these
troops
not just for beach marking anymore but
for straight-up commando operations they
have the army's curriculum they have all
the experience of working with army
commandos
so they
train their sailors and everything that
the army commanders have been trained
with and they the plan is to send these
uh send these units to china and that's
the amphibious rogers so the scouts and
raiders uh naturally they i have a
picture i think in the book of uh
there's a sign you know it says scouts
and raiders and then underneath it the
amphibious rogers within months there's
no more scouts in raiders sign it's the
amphibious rogers
so
not the best name
for a commando unit but the idea was
that uh you know the these were the the
navy's pirates you know the rogers
the jolly roger these guys are supposed
to be the swaggering you know
bushwackers of the pacific
uh
chapter seven the u.s navy's post-war
plight
and the sailor raiders who led her back
to significance in korea
um
again there's just so much detail that
you put into this it's f absolutely
fascinating to read you end up
highlighting now we're in i'll fast
forward to where in
korea
um target baker
this time the scouts were accompanied by
a boatload of marines who upon landing
established a hasty perimeter then
flashed seaward the signal for all clear
when the remaining boats hit the shore
the marines secured a beach head then
scouted inland for the tunnel entrance
as they did two trains appeared and did
the job for them revealing the location
of the two rail tunnels to the
southernmost the scouts put to flight
one century armed with nothing but a
wooden rifle in a bayonet
after securing the southern tunnel the
udt swimmers slogged some 2 thousand
pounds of explosives 300 yards past the
beach where they stacked pack after pack
into the tunnel's mouth and under a
bridge at
0-305 the udt swimmers pulled their
fuses initiating a hasty six-minute
retreat to the beach and the boats
followed by a concert of oars through
the surf at 3 30
noted the task force diary charges
exploded 20 minutes later the men of sog
climbed back into the bat into the bass
which was the ship and into history as
the navy's first successful raiders of
the modern area era for joy and for many
of the navy planners it was just a start
yeah that was a tough chapter sorry that
was a tough chapter to sort of figure
out what where the center of gravity of
this thing is like what because the i
mean just the the number of raider
organizations that the navy sponsors
during this period they sponsor uh the
marine corps udt group which is uh the
special operations group at the time the
saag
they spawn they sponsor uh udt led
british commandos they sponsor uh army
uh raiders they i mean everybody is
trying to figure out how to
uh you know
do sort of what the koreans were doing
to the us military at that point which
is bottled up in the busan perimeter
there's it's it's like uh you know we've
been watching a busan perimeter moment
in afghanistan the their
uh
lack of leadership lack of planning
lack of resourcing uh you know forces uh
the army or the u.s forces back into
this this small pocket and they're doing
everything they can to sort of not
necessarily break out of it but at least
uh you know not do nothing and the not
doing nothing is
trying to uh you know cut the north
koreans uh supply lines and and the one
advantage that they have
when with the korean peninsula is all of
these arteries all these roads because
of the the spine of the the north korean
geography as they push everything to the
to the edges of
the peninsula
so this is the first time the navy
really sees it you know this huge
opportunity to start you know sponsoring
raids ashore
that's the first time that the the udt
which is the only special operations uh
unit that survives disbandment in world
war ii uh that's the that's the moment
that they cease to be just beach marking
or just reconnaissance troops and
demolition troops and they start going
ashore but they you know like every
other instance
they are going sure not alone they're
going ashore with the marines with
british commandos cia operatives
partisans
and they're slowly uh learning
uh this trade
you go into uh chapter eight here tells
another story of the rangers
and
the army resurrection of the army
rangers and the gorilla raid that failed
to forestall their second death
um
just just another one of these
uh you got a guy named
john hugh mcgee
these characters all of them they're
freaking epic
i
i mean what this guy did um
is just
incredible um his career
you look at these guys career
um
and some and i mean at least in john
mcgee's case i mean he he's a totally uh
i mean he he maybe has the worst world
war ii experience of anybody
let me just jump into that real quick um
a year later mcgee was at the epicenter
of history hopelessly commanding moro
troops in the philippines against
japanese bombers in the snake choked
malarial hills around del monte field
del monte airfield
at kilometer 117 of the sare highway
becoming the only american of the 11 who
fought to there to survive the war
after six months of resistance on may 10
1942 mcgee swallowed his pride obeyed
his superior and with a humiliating
blindfolded salute surrendered himself
and his american and filipino troops to
imperious japanese officer wearing a
kimono many of the filipinos were tied
to stake shot and buried in pits the
japanese soldiers never bothering to
confirm they were dead at 33 mcgee's
dark brown hair had already faded into
an iron gray for the next 25 months
mcgee survived beatings trench foot
dysentery malaria mosquitoes cages and
slavery for nourishment he and his
fellow prisoners were fed a meager diet
of rice and a few vegetables that
occasionally included yams dog meat
wafer thing candy bars and cigarettes
the last two purchased with a monthly
allotment of 40 pesos that the japanese
could turn into a lever to pry prisoners
submission
so sensitive did the men become to their
hunger that when fearful of transfer
they gorged themselves on every scrap
they had hidden one man even devouring a
litter of puppies born the same day
along with his catholic faith to which
he cleaved mcgee sustained his mind on a
series of escape plans
into the philippine jungle even making
use of a urinary tract infection that
kept him up at night to memorize the
guideposts of the constellations
to each plan was attached in obvious
cholera colorary
obvious to him anyways
once escaped he would raise and lead an
army of filipino guerrillas against the
japanese for two years he plotted
mentally choosing men for work details
not for strength but for their knowledge
and gunnery and logistics men around
whom he could build the guerrilla army
in his mind on the night of june 12th
two years one month and two days after
his capture he finally got his chance
while anchored off the east coast of
zamboanga peninsula on a prison transfer
ship mcgee palmed off his rosary beads
to a friend dropped every stitch of his
ragged clothing to the deck then tiptoed
over his sleeping comrades placed a
naked foot on top of the railing and
dove into the racing current
through an initial volley of the through
an initial volley of bullets and past
two other prison ships mcgee drifted for
miles until rescued by a native by a
native in an outrigger who paddled him
to land gave him a t-shirt which mcgee
turned into a loincloth ashore two
native boys eventually found fed and
clothed him tied undersized sneakers to
the bottom of his feet like heel-less
slippers then pushed and pulled his
emaciated frame over jungle trails lit
by nothing more than a torch as bright
as a cigar tip and you go on from there
but just you have to kind of realize
what's happening with this guy and where
this guy came from
and what he wants yeah he he spends the
entire war you know
essentially just neutralized yeah well
it's
so he's in prison camp for two years
when he finally escapes he wants to go
run a run a freaking an army a guerrilla
army well there's other people that had
already been running a guerrilla army
and they and now they outrank him they
have the experiences so he kind of gets
sidelined the whole time his war is just
a series of disappointments
yeah so he and and
when he gets back home you know to he
finally meets the daughter uh that his
wife uh he meets he meets his daughter
who's never met before and uh his
reaction is immediately to volunteer for
service back in the uh in the pacific
theater and the day he gets back the day
he takes command of his his troops uh
they drop the they drop the bomb
and the entire time i mean that he's
been you know neutralized this entire
time facing these series of disbandments
his little brother
has been one of merrell's
meryl's marauders uh most effective uh
battalion commanders
which is a really frustrating thing for
this poor guy
the psychology behind that yeah so when
he finally gets to korea
uh and you know he has this new
opportunity to prove himself all he
wants to do
is create the you know the the army that
he had built in his mind and
he gets there and or
anyway you have the
there's a
there's a so they go they end up he ends
up putting together kind of a group
mcgee's rangers
he's the uh um
he's the indispensable person when it
comes to army special operations in
korea everything sort of flows out of
him uh he has all these ideas at the
beginning of the war and he puts them
all in writing and
so everything from the
the army rangers are
reconstituted based off of his
recommendations uh the partisan command
is created based off of his
recommendations uh and he wants to sort
of uh combine these these units together
he's got this idea it's sort of unformed
it's not uh it's not exactly what it's
not a mature idea uh um
at the beginning of the war it becomes
you know you you see when you when you
look through the structure of the
institution that he had uh sort of
created you see
like uh like a siege of soda yeah like
the components yeah like they're there
like you can see and and every time that
he constitutes this thing he the navy is
a critical part of his ideas you can't
do any of the types of things that he
wants to do unless you have significant
navy support navy transports uh anyway
so
the problem is you know the the army
uh has moved pia moved past all of his
ideas they you know they uh they
entertain him they entertain these ideas
for a period uh and uh as you see
throughout uh uh his service the army
plucks these things off the table one at
a time
leaving him uh to go back to you know
the states not in disgrace but not not
to fulfill the thing that he wants
he got these he's got these ranger
groups together again and here's a
here's a section where the rangers are
his some of his mcgee's rangers are
going out they're on an operation i'm
going to jump into the middle of this
operation after a moment of intense
argument watson ordered back one of the
koreans they had left their radio
watson ordered back one of the
koreans to get the radio who not
surprisingly refused until watson
threatened to beat the man himself
scrambling to the clearing the korean
soldier seized the radio by the
backstrap then dragged it behind him
bouncing rolling smashing over rocks and
leaving a trail of broken knobs handles
and antennae bastards got his brains in
his ass seethed watson as he watched
when the runner reached the trees and
presented the radio everyone could see
that it was destroyed with their only
hope for survival buoyed upon the
ability to communicate their position to
the navy's fighters and helicopters the
radio's destruction meant virginia
that's the name of the team virginia's
was not far behind had watson wanted to
repay this cruelty and kind his rage was
instantly short-circuited by the
shredding sound of a machine gun fire
and the terror of communist soldiers
lunging across the body strewn clearing
without a word as thornton recalled the
virginia survivors plunged into the
trees and careened down the hill in a
wild melee
stumbling rising running and falling
again hoping with every bruise to break
through to the valley floor before the
enemy cinched the noose around their
necks after running for what seemed like
a half a mile the men collapsed into the
relative protection and shadow of a
ravine as their lungs
pumped miniature fog banks into the cold
air their ears caught the growing but
unmistakable hum of hum and chop of two
helicopters echoing through the valley
when the first helicopter made it back
to the clearing its pilot aged into a
hover kicked out a bundle of supplies
then leaned out his window coming face
to face with a volley of muzzle flashes
banking hard the pilot escaped and
ambushed the ambush only barely with the
clearing obviously overrun both pilots
rode rolled their helicopters into an
anxious racetrack search around the
mountains flying solo that thornton
could easily make out each pilot's face
without a radio even without even
marking panels the vagina virginia
survivors waved frantic arms but
betrayed not a sound since any noise
would only alert their hunters not the
engine deafened pilots
for 30 or so minutes the pilots searched
then ascended and retraced their path to
the ocean
virginia was alone
except for the blowing wind and the
rustle of the leafless trees remembered
thornton
there was silence lonely empty silence
[Music]
they go on the run you you highlight you
you go through some of that and then
finally fast forward a little bit on
april 10th 10 hallucinatory days since
the mountaintop battle in just two to
three miles from un lines the last
remaining members of virginia mission
were cornered in a cave captured and
ransacked then beaten and bound with
wire so tightly that watson's arms soon
swelled to twice their normal size for
the second time in his life this veteran
of the darby's rangers was a prisoner of
war as fate would have it captured while
escaping from a disaster as
consequential for the rangers as
cisterna had been
and this guy watson you you um you you
introduce him later and you have to get
the book to see what this guy's about
but let me give you a little something
so this guy get gets captured in the 29
months since his capture corporal martin
r watson a soldier no guard or prisoner
believed was actually a corporal had set
an example for captivity that to this
day was has never been exceeded
30 days after he was captured
for 18 of which he had been starved in a
cave to make his 240 pound size somewhat
easier to handle watson and a south
korean comrade had knocked out a guard
with a rock and made for the surrounding
mountains where they had survived for
five days until their pursuers had
disabled them by rolling a grenade into
their hideout
never medically treated except with some
shreds of brown paper to cover his wound
wounds watson had nevertheless escaped
again this time by wriggling out of his
rope restraints and jumping free of a
moving truck as it slowed around a bend
this time he survived a week before
inadvertently walking right past a
wide-eyed north korean patrol
for these attempts and one other plus an
attempt at suicide with a piece of
broken glass he had been relentlessly
beaten with rifle butts and boot heels
and periodically starved and always
almost always isolated
once in an unsheltered hole for 72 days
with rations described by the record as
sparse
rightly suspected as an oss spy and
saboteur watson had also been subjected
to almost daily interrogation by north
koreans chinese and even russians who
had drilled him up on his exposure to
the gestapo in world war ii but
especially on the organization's methods
and tactics of the paratroop unit to
which they knew he belonged
watson's response to these and other
questions had been a mixture of stony
silence or intentional contradiction
responses that had invariably earned him
a switch across the eyes a pistol barrel
across the face or hours of kneeling
with his nose pressed against a wall and
then a stone on his head
throughout these deprivations watson had
never lost his bearing or conviction
once standing during a packed camp
lecture by a british speaker from the
london daily worker to say that he
didn't know what communism was and he
didn't care to find out
nor did he and his fellow pows want to
listen to this traitor commie son of a
[ __ ]
for this affront
and as his example to other prisoners he
was eventually frog marched before a
military tribunal informed of the
armistice then sentenced to death by
firing squad
he still didn't talk
in the end after having been starved
from 240 pounds to 120
his was an example that earned him the
final distinction as the second to last
u n p o w to be released across the
freedom bridge
on the other side he learned that the
rangers he had so steadfastly protected
from exposure
no longer
existed as far removed now from the
army's interest as was the man who had
resurrected them from the grave a man
whose accomplishments had
disappointingly matched those of his
past
about the same time that operation
spitfire had been unraveling colonel
john hugh mcgee the korean war author of
the army rangers and korean partisans
had presented himself for the third time
to the quonsen hut maze of the 8th
army's headquarters in busan intent on
securing a date for a partisan advance
into north korea a date for which he had
long been waiting
the reply from his superior had been
simple
never
after a year-long tour mcgee left korea
as dejected as he had left the
philippines never again to have a chance
to lead a partisan army on a campaign of
liberation
on top of everything else he was branded
the scapegoat for the failure of
virginia and spitfire failures with
consequences beyond a battered
reputation
yeah
i mean the
the way that the army is treating
special operations in this period is um
similar to the way that they dealt with
them in in world war ii they created the
rangers they attached them to divisions
for control in each instance the
divisional commanders they don't see
much distinction between the rangers in
their own infantry so they treat them
like infantry and
usually they use them as their front
line infantry and
predictably they get mauled and then the
commanders justify their own belief that
they were just like infantry
so the only thing that really could have
kept the rangers of the army from
disbanding them would have been the sort
of raid that
mcgee sends watson and his team to
complete which is a a penetration rate
at a deep uh you know a deep penetration
rate um behind enemy lines to destroy a
tunnel
for
lots of reasons uh the the rug gets
pulled out from under the this team
before they even go uh and their chances
of success before they even launch are
diminished and almost nothing they still
go and
like you read that passage that you read
i mean the survival the lengths that
they go just to survive
are incredible um and this mission is
almost completely lost to history
i mean when i started researching that
mission
and researching watson i
didn't have a lot to go on there's
really only a couple of accounts about
it uh and i had you know based off of
what i had done uh the research i'd done
from for my world war ii chapters i sort
of knew or i sort of suspected that
there would be like some uh post pow
report about watson couldn't find it
well the first time i went to the
archives but
uh
i knew that these reports were roughly
you know two pages whenever anybody was
recovered from a pow camp the military
would interview them they would put the
the circumstances their capture uh and
the circumstances of of
their captivity in these reports and you
know they'd you know lock it away in a
an archive someplace
so i knew that this report probably
existed so i
contacted the archives they confirmed
that the report did exist and i you know
being in illinois at the time it wasn't
super convenient for me to go back i
expected that you know you know the the
two pages wouldn't provide a ton of
detail anyway but i asked them could you
take a look at it uh and then send me
the pages that uh you know his of his
report
they the the archivist was kind enough
to do it she went she looked at the the
account she said yeah the the accounts
in a you know file you know labeled such
and such is the uh the record of
american uh pows in the korean war but
it's 750 pages so i can't
scan it and copy it and send it to you
it's like well can you just find his
section and then send me those pages and
she said no it's 750 pages it's not been
cleared you'd have to put a foia request
in just to go through it to make sure
that there's no you know classified
information so i put the foia request in
they go through but they still won't
send me the two pages anyway i sort of
forget about it
i've sort of moved on to another chapter
i figure if i'm going to find anything
on the virginia one raid and it's going
to be the you know the center of gravity
of that chapter i'll find it eventually
but i it's sort of like i said i put it
on the back burner i've already moved on
so i i come to the archive uh several
months later and i remember i put this
foia request in so you know i do a
double check on it at the end of a long
day my back is aching because of all the
pictures that i've taken you have to
stand over these uh these tables and you
know take picture after picture and when
i leave these you know the archive after
a day of research i've got like three
thousand images
you know it's it's
it's a you know
it's not fun but
at the end of the day i think i've got
about 30 minutes left i find the
archives i'm like hey can you find this
report for me i'd like to take a look at
it and see what it is
she comes back with the 750 pages i open
it up
it's not
750 pages of american pows in the korean
war it's 750 pages on martin watson
and no one has ever gone through it
not since the day
that they
took the reports and put it in the
archive
and it is
it's a gold mine
i mean it had everything from his police
reports uh the circumstances of his
captivity in cisterna uh because he was
part of darby's rangers crazy and then
the fact that this person he's present
not just for you know the the
consequential moment of the rangers in
world war ii but the consequential
moment of the rangers in the korean war
um
and it's amazing account after account
of all the people that you know it's not
just his interview it's not his just his
post captivity interview that's in the
750 pages it's interview after interview
by his fellow captives
and they all have the same story about
this guy
he is incomparable
and he gets a bronze star
actress you know after his captivity uh
and he gets a promotion to sergeant i
mean i couldn't i mean
maybe freeman
in some instances maybe halperin a
couple of others i mean nobody that i
come across in the in the writing of
that book is more deserving of the medal
of honor i mean the the length that he
went to for his own uh uh for his own
men uh on that hilltop in the virginia
one mission and then the lengths that he
goes to just to survive uh in the pow
camps and and to escape numerous escapes
i mean
but yeah he's
i mean i do have your next book
identified yet
i got a good idea
the problem with the the the um
uh
the record is there's that there's no
dates
uh and i've thought you know you could
write a book about martin watson i think
you would have to make it fiction though
you'd have enough uh material to write
that that book but you couldn't write it
with the same level uh of specificity
that i wrote this because you need the
chronology to tell that story and the
chronology don't you think you could
piece together the chronology from
the other of the events that he's
actually in and you could have thought
about it and you would have to find
you'd have to uh go through each of the
reports
uh and and track down you know the you
know the 100 150 guys and see who's
still alive to see if they can put you
know some chronology to it you it would
i don't know i have i've thought about
it
um what happened to him after the war
after he got out of the army after he
was meritoriously promoted to sergeants
right
he is uh
it doesn't have the it's it's not the
best uh
uh epitaph he's um
he ends up having some trouble i mean
like like i write in the book uh his
inter-war period between uh his uh
release from um uh the german pow camp
in world war ii and the uh his entrance
back into the army it's punctuated by
some 76 arrests by the the connecticut
police
and yeah ranging from fighting to
drunkenness back to fighting to
resisting arrest i mean he has no uh i
mean he clearly has you know
post-traumatic stress but he's also you
know that's just who he was just he's
grown up in this sort of like rough and
tumble gang type environment
um
and you know he's
he's you know he would be a nightmare to
command but you know also you know
incomparable in combat
but after the war uh he he marries uh it
doesn't doesn't go well um he's you know
completely you know uh broken from the
war he ends up having a couple of kids
um
uh and then moving to alaska to work on
a pipeline uh his son who i uh have
become you know friends with uh is every
bit as big as his old man was i mean
he's uh he's just a you know some
equally a monster
uh but the nicest guy he'd ever meet
um
but he think he met his dad you know
maybe two dozen times in the course of
his life
and then his he passes away i believe
from lung cancer he smoked his entire
entire life and
the password that his son
would have to use to get into his
hospital room
was courage
so
[Music]
korean war ends um
uh
your next section is arleigh burke the
bay of pigs
and the launching of the navy's limited
war seals
you talk about early here
during the period of the cia's
preparations for the covert evasion
invasion of cuba the u.s navy was led by
admiral arlee burke
the 58 year old cno whose most
conspicuous feature
were a tight shock of curly bleached
hair a fist
of a chin that fell into a loose and
swollen neck
and a sizable bulk that had long since
settled into his hips
a trait that gave said one witness a sea
roll to his stride and to join his shape
the impression of an upright base
or a freighter
so there you go arleigh burke um
not an attractive man
yeah and here's an important part and
this is one of the one of the parts
where we start connecting this dna of
the seal teams to the the dna of the of
the us navy in 1943 when burke finally
arrived in the south pacific to take
command of disc destroyer squadron 23
desron 23
the little beavers he pinned himself to
a drop leaf desk in a sweltering belly
of his command ship and crammed into his
head a year's worth of combat reports
every battle from coral sea to savo
island
appalled at the micromanagement of
destroyers
in which the permission to launch
torpedoes against an already discovered
enemy fleet was denied four for four
immutable minutes burke crafted an
entirely new doctrine of employment
instead of spreading his destroyers
around the fleet's larger ships as
nighttime submarine submarine pickets
all dependent on permission from above
to break guard duty to engage the enemy
burke proposed to concentrate his ships
at the head of the fleet and to govern
his skipper's skippers
under what has since been called the
doctrine of faith an unprecedented
delegation of authority in which an
enemy sighting would be immediately
followed by a coordinated torpedo attack
without
orders the use of all caps was berks to
convey this attitude to his sailors
burke issued them a 12-page mimeographed
memo whose very first lines read if it
will help kill japs it's important if it
would not help kill japs it's not
important
keep your ship trained for battle
burke's list of non-battle related
orders was succinct
there were none
corrections to this section will not be
permitted
it took less than a month to make his
point
so that's burke
you you go through this thing and burke
is running the navy and
you know clearly he's an aggressive guy
and believes in decentralized command um
you do a great job of covering
what happened at the bay of pigs how
that ties into our history and the seal
teams um
really pretty interesting story the way
that unfolds and and you know it ends up
with
well it's a horrible situation but we do
gain some experience that we then take
we work with some of these some of these
cuban nationalists that
helped us out as well yeah
and this is the toughest chapter well
that's not the toughest chapter each of
the chapters presented you know various
challenges when it came to researching
and trying to like you know craft the
narrative or trying to figure out like
like i said before what's the what's the
point of this chapter and how does this
uh
how does how does this serve the story
or how did this push us forward
and you know what aspects of of you know
burke's personality or burke's own
history uh how is that relevant and
absolutely you're you know you hit the
nail right on the head when it comes to
you know burke's uh you know emphasis on
latitude and decentralized command but
the other thing about burke that's
really important or it's that's
essential about him is that he uh
refuses to allow the other branches of
service to define what the navy is and
you know in the revolt of the admirals
during that period um during uh the uh
you know the the inner war period
between world war ii and the korean war
you know the the other branches of the
service are trying to tell the navy that
you know
we need to really de-arm ourselves and
become sort of just a you know more of a
you know a merchant marine which to
burke is anathema he has no interest
in uh commanding a navy that's just a
support or a transport unit
to burke the navy is nothing if it's not
an uh an instrument of offensive warfare
uh and so he's constantly when he
becomes the cno and he becomes a cno for
a period long
two years longer than even the the
closest his closest competitor it's
normally a two-year job he's the cno for
six years
no one has the influence on the us navy
that arleigh burke does
so when he becomes a cno
he's constantly the entire time he's
constantly looking for opportunities to
push the navy uh into you know a more
offensive role so he champions this uh
this limited war capability you know he
sees enemies all over the the globe and
he's trying to figure out how the navy
can you know can either
bring forces to bear launch marines
launch missiles launch you know naval
gunfire
and and that you know uh orientation uh
ultimately uh creates creates this unit
um
but
like i said
writing the book creates you know you
know presents uh you know structuring
and research challenges uh you know
every chapter is hard to write um
this chapter though this was probably
the easiest chapter when it came to
write the first draft
because there's been so much uh produced
about arleigh burke
numerous books a couple of them are
pretty good
with you know lots and lots of
corroborative detail in them and then
you know just finding you know his
fingerprints all over those uh those
documents that create the seal teams
they're all over i mean everything all
the all the documents that his office is
creating but then you can see his little
scratches and his pen scratches and all
these documents because he he writes
with i think it's a green pen and you
can see him still on the documents when
you go to the the
navy yard today
the problem with this chapter
particularly the bay of pig's part is
just finding the material because it's
you know the cia is still involved and
you know i can't tell you how many times
i tried to get documents out of the cia
it's a black hole you just can't get
them so i finally was able to track down
the actual cuban frogmen
that
participated in the raid and all of them
were just you know
totally generous with their time so you
know the book is written almost
sequentially there's a couple of
chapters that i wrote out of order but
this chapter in particular is the one
that just sort of kept me up at night
until the end so like i i know there's
more material out there and i've got to
get it into the book and i mean short of
going down to miami uh and and meeting
with the the actual
or because they closed the museum they
closed the bay a big museum
but i managed to find them and their
accounts are in there
yeah it's a it's an epic epic retelling
of that
um
again that's why you got to get this
book to read these sections
because i'm not covering it all today uh
but we do get kennedy we get kennedy who
now is really focused on this idea the
small war idea the counter insurgency
idea the guerrilla warfare idea he's all
over it he starts pushing people in that
direction he needs someone to run
the the special warfare center at fort
bragg which is where the green berets
come from where they get it's like their
school house
um he ends up
talking to one of his friends his one of
his military aides who who recommends a
guy to run it this guy named colonel
bill yarbrough
who's another character in the story
at the change of command ceremony his
his soldiers observed him as he was
average size chest out shoulders back a
rooster of a man his narrowed eyes and
pursed lips locked into a stoic gaze as
revealing as a roman bust son of an army
colonel married to an army brat with a
son on his way to an army commission and
two daughters on their way to army
husbands yarborough was a the very
picture of army tradition 48 years old
now in press slacks and blouse boots
with no prior special no prior
experience in special forces nothing on
the surface seemed to indicate anything
besides a conventional background and a
preference for more of the same but that
was just the surface beneath his obvious
soldierly bearing was hidden an ambition
for a military organization as
unconventional as had ever existed born
into a military family and predictably
funneled into a west point education
where his only step out of formation
seems to have been as a cartoonist on
the school newspaper yarborough's early
army career was in fact a litany of
non-conformities
four years with the philippine scouts
one of the most unconventional
assignments in the us army two years as
a parachute test officer during which
his creativity had burst open as wide as
the thing he was testing
this had manifested in
everything from redesigning the
paratroopers pants to boots to promoting
his untested unit by acting as a stunt
double for a hollywood movie for which
he was afterwards afterward nicknamed
showbiz
and in creating a silver badge that
looked like an ice cream cone-shaped
parachute flexed with winged angels that
was ultimately adopted as the symbol for
the entire airborne in world war two
yarborough survived incomparable five
combat jumps five com campaigns two
combat commands one of which had fought
alongside darby's rangers at cisterna
and later earned a unit presidential
unit citation and one crash landing and
except for a brief sidelining resulting
from an outburst against his division
commander matthew ridgway it was an
almost unblemished record of direct
action with a record a record with honor
so compelling that any normal soldier
would have coveted its repetition
yarborough wasn't normal
what was the outburst about ridgeway
remember
yeah i'm trying to think it was uh
it was a
it was an errant drop
i believe in italy
uh an errand drop of the parachute
troopers or an air drop of a bomb
friendly fire situation no of
paratroopers okay yeah they they landed
them uh in a place that they shouldn't
have landed them and he returns from
that and he
uh he does something that you just can't
do in the army he he you know lets his
boss have it
and matthew ridgeway is not matthew
ridgeway is another you know hero of the
story but you know maybe not a hero of
the story he's a hero he's an american
hero but he's an executioner of the
rangers in korea but he's also the
executioner of yarbrough's sort of
rise to infantry or
paratrooper greatness he uh he
short-circuits his career sends him back
to the states i think the only way that
yarbrough gets back into command is
through mark clark
um but yeah it was um
uh
yeah yarbrough yarbrough yarbo he is uh
probably next to kauffman
i don't think i met anybody uh
who
was as tough as just sort of pinned down
like what does he want because i mean
his whole background seems to imply that
he's
you know just this conventional you know
soldier but he has no interest in it and
i you know that i i couldn't find uh you
know the letter the document uh to you
know suggest you know why he um was sort
of turning his back on that and why he
you know bought in so you know
full-heartedly to this uh idea of
counter-insurgency but nevertheless it's
there he becomes the biggest uh disciple
or apostle or whatever you want to call
him of counter insurgency of you know
winning uh you know the the
the hearts and minds of the people uh
and then turning them or at least
denying them to the enemy and
the way that you did that is not through
combat
it's through all the stuff that nobody
likes to do it's digging well yeah
digging in
it becomes real obvious is you saying
here yarborough's first action is
commander of the naval special warfare
center and top train of special forces
was to initiate a top to bottom review
of training curriculum and effort to
match his men with their mission so here
we go into
fast forward a little bit before long
the special warfare center began to feel
less like a commando course and more
like a college campus complete with
courses in bridge building sanitation
animal husbandry blacksmithing crop
raising pig pen construction swine
inoculation leaflet creation field
irrigation seed planting and rice
cultivation
not all of yarbrough and and of course
there's resistance not all of
yarbrough's staff are proved to the
changes particularly said yarbrough the
old jockstrap commandos the ranger types
gallant bloodletters and fighting
machines to be sure but men who were
anything but diplomats and rejected any
suggestion that they ought to be they
were he continued men devoid of the more
humane qualities compassion pity and
mercy
men who bristled at the idea of lying on
their bellies to teach an illiterate
tribesman on how to aim a rifle
so he's got a totally different idea of
really what the green berets should be
and he's got another little
he's got another little different
opinion too here fast forward a little
bit to convert his men to his new
philosophy as warfare my religion he
would one day call it in which battles
the battle's objective was not the
destruction of the enemy of an enemy's
army but the winning of indigenous minds
and sympathies that must be the
precursor to hearts and minds
yarborough enjoined every one of his
officers above the rank of captain to
accompany him into the pine barrens for
what he called his talk in the woods
as long as i am charged with special
forces he would say there will be no
womanizing no drunkenness no wild
parties no adultery there'll be no
troublemakers no wild men that stuff is
out there will be moral stand standards
disciplinary standards appearance
standards the rules are going to change
he would promise there will be a new
start
so he's
coming hard he's coming hard and uh
this that chapter in particular so i've
talked about some of the challenges of
other chapters and you know either you
know finding material or figuring out
what the chapter is about and how that
chapter served the the larger story the
the story of the special forces
uh presented a problem but i was not
prepared for
um
every chapter took about you know
between six
around six seven months to write
uh
when i got to
and and and they all followed a similar
pattern you know whether the uh
whether the the uh
the unit was um
a navy unit that we're talking about
where it's uh being created uh committed
to action and then it's retained in the
order of battle or whether it's an army
or marine corps unit that is uh created
and then disbanded uh there was there
was this pattern uh that was sort of
predictable you know navy unit created
army unit disbanded or marine corps
whatever when you get to uh
and it fit with you know my
understanding of my thesis which was
um
the navy's continuing to fill this gap
in in the order of battle and
um
that held until the special forces when
i get to the special forces like my
thesis sort of like started to crumble
and i had this moment of like panic
where i was like
i mean the only thing i can do is just
ignore the entire existence of the
special forces because it's i mean it
doesn't fit with what i've been doing
for the past you know seven years
um and
when i you know obviously that's not
what i did i
think
because it's not the right thing to do
because you're telling a history you
have to you know understand the
relationship you can't just change
history to figure the story i mean you i
mean there's so many times if you're
writing history that you know the
temptation is there you want to you know
make the facts fit your narrative it's
not that's not honest and it's not what
you're supposed to do so
i ended up having to take an entire year
and did nothing but you know
really
learn the history of the army special
forces which is a fascinating history
but it also you know revealed
within you know three or four months
that it wasn't the fact that the special
forces was you know created committed to
action and disbanded it was that they
were completely reoriented to a
non-commando type mission and no one was
more uh
consequential in that um
uh shift than yarborough
yeah they they end up the gap that all
these other raider units would fill and
then get disbanded he didn't go into
that gap he went into this other gap he
went to this other gap and then there
was a gap that was created uh by
president kennedy
and uh
and trying to connect those two people i
couldn't figure it out until i found
that article about spartacus about
kennedy watching this movie and he gets
oh yeah tell that story i i'm not going
to cover it but tell that story in the
in the months leading up to um
his inauguration he's uh um he's been
elected but he hasn't yet uh become
president uh
he gets uh his his brother tells him how
great uh the movie of the kirk douglas
movie spartacus is and he you know
uh his you know uh
incoming secretary of the navy uh
happens to be going as an extra ticket
you know mr president like would you
like to go
so he goes and uh the movie's already
started the theater owner sees cat you
know kennedy come in stops everything
brings them upstairs they have a cup of
coffee together everybody all the other
theater goers are just waiting for them
to start so it goes down with a cup of
coffee uh restarts the movie and he
watches this thing and he comes out and
he's i mean it's a
if you've ever seen you know spartacus
it's a you know it's the epic i mean
when i was a kid i saw it it was i mean
i've never seen anything like it in
um
and it makes an impression on him and
where you know it's a it's a slave army
um that you know is fighting across uh
italy and they're liberating other
slaves and they're turning them into
gladiators
and that's what kennedy wants to do yeah
and he sees in this movie he sees an
answer to his problem you know
we're going to turn these you know
legions of uh you know third world you
know uh
um
people into you know our army of freedom
and yarbo brought into that bought into
it oh yeah
meanwhile fast forward a little bit
um chapter 11.
one o'clock on january 1st 1962 on
monday seal team one was without fanfare
of any kind
unceremoniously commissioned on naval
amphibious base coronado right where the
neck of san diego's palm tree resort
island met the flat seven mile long
sandy isthmus called the silver strand
located on this base a peninsula of
military-grade right angles that jutted
out into the sparkling waters of san
diego bay the team's physical footprint
was little more than a single world war
ii era quonset hut
the team's authorized strength was for
10 officers and 50 enlisted men most of
whom had not yet been pulled from their
west coast underwater demolition teams
the man most responsible for recruiting
equipping and training these men
was their 29 year old commanding officer
lieutenant david del
giudice just outside of newark new
jersey by italian speaking working-class
parents del judas was of average height
and athletic build and like nearly every
other frog man well tanned
as an officer except for you
as an officer at udt12 he had been
selected to lead a 10-man detachment to
vietnam on a two-week trip up the mekong
river to deliver landing craft to
laotian troops troops that the army
special forces were already training for
combat briefed on the insurgents and the
menu of reptiles that he and his men
were sure to encounter they had seen
neither just a hundred miles of mud
browned river
now del judas was in charge of a unit
that had been created in no small part
to return to that river but to what end
no one quite knew
so there you go
seal teams get commissioned
and
and this is when all the history
finally you know starts to collide it
collides yeah it culminates in this and
and you know the
the the the individual it collides in is
uh phil buckley who is
um who's been there uh
at the literally from the beginning of
naval special warfare and he you know
i'm there's there's a reason that you
know the naval special warfare center is
named after this person the phil h
buckley center for naval special awards
yeah i mean it wouldn't i mean
he
uh he doesn't create you know the the
scouts and raiders doesn't create the
udts he doesn't
create the seal teams
but he's there for these critical
moments
to help the seal teams along and his
his ability to
form relationships his ability to write
because he was obviously and he's super
humble
and and is able to get his conveyor's
message apart
yeah convey his message
in such a way that really there's only
one answer but he never gives the answer
it's like he allows people to discover
the truth for themselves which is the
best way to get people to discover the
truths better than i could have said it
yes
i wish i had that in there
yeah he writes these uh we'll we'll get
to it
phil h buckley when he had left his
house on december 7th 1941 phil hinkle
buckley was a six foot two inch 235
pound former fullback for the cleveland
rams whose major concern that morning
had been to choose one of the four
football contracts burning a hole in his
pocket with thinning hair and a heavy
jaw a curled lip and down turned eyes
not to mention a torso as thick as a
tree trunk buckle at 26 looked 10 years
older than he was and was 10 times as
mean
while intimidating from a distance
buckle up close actually possessed a
purchase personality that accomplished
the opposite he had never attracted to
his orbit enough players to found and
coach his own football team
the or sorry he had even attracted
enough
players to his orbit to found and coach
his own football team the columbus
bullies
a team on its way to another league
championship had the japanese not
exploded the afternoon as they did if i
would have known about the columbus
bullies my task in attacking a bruiser
might have been the task unit bullies
instead but one of those things
um
in the sicily campaign he had checked it
checked the beach himself and fast
forward a little bit then signaled the
fleet from the bobbing shell of a
blackened kayak while screaming balls of
fire skipped off the water around him in
the weeks before normandy invasion he
skimmed to the coast and collected
density testing bottom samples to up to
20 yards from the shore
then evaded a flotilla of six enemy
trawlers and a crash of bullet snaps
from
mg-42 machine gun by escaping into the
knight and fog on the smoke grey dawn of
d-day buckley and his lct scout boat
crew led the first wave of floating
tanks to omaha beach fired ear splitting
rockets and twin 50 cal machine guns to
silence an enemy pillbox then spent the
day throttling through red clouded water
and mine topped obstacles to pluck
drowning soldiers from burning landing
craft
fast forward for a service in world war
ii buckled received an unheard of number
of commendations a bronze star for north
africa a silver star for salerno and
then then a brace of navy crosses one
for sicily another for omaha beach not
even his friend and fellow footballer
buck halperin had been awarded as many
naturally such a record had opened doors
to more unconventional opportunities
including two and a half years in korea
more than twice the length of a standard
war tour where buckley had doubled as
the navy's representative to the cia and
led the beach jumpers a navy unit
created to collect and jam the enemy's
electronic communications or
periodically mimic them to sow chaos in
their transmissions
so there's just some of the stuff that
you talk about that that buckles got
going on
and that's a that's another one of those
units too the beach jumpers right
another one of these random units that
the navy puts together freaking just get
some
um
so he's got to write this report
talk about why he had to write the
support report uh he had to write the
report because uh the original commander
got sent home and the reason that the
original commander of the uh
the commission or the survey team
uh
we don't know if he was sent home for a
health problem or uh as one person said
for a closet drunkenness um but
they i mean the the the point of this
report that they're sent to
to create is to figure out what the hell
the navy's supposed to do in vietnam
it's not uh it's not a theater that
any naval commander is eager to you know
insert himself into um
there's no arleigh burke uh at the helm
of the navy at this point so uh the the
character of uh you know naval
leadership is slightly different maybe
not as aggressive um but they still want
to you know see what the navy can do so
they send the survey team but the the
people that they select for this survey
team are almost um you know they're sort
of uh
um
uh they're way they're waiting the
scales a little bit i mean they send uh
david deljudis who is uh you know he's
the commanding officer of seal team one
uh they send uh phil kaler who's a
former uh udt guy from uh the pacific
theater a silver star winner and they
said phil bucklow is the second in
command who is you know nobody has had a
more inland uh naval experience uh in
outside of the seal teams than this guy
and make him the number two uh the
commanding officer gets sent home
putting phil buckler in charge of this
report they spend the next uh six weeks
two months uh you know hopscotching the
country trying to figure out what to do
and um
the report that he creates is entirely
his i mean uh
he
lets no one else take the responsibility
for this report he drafts it himself uh
he types it himself even he doesn't have
a yeoman to do it he did you see
original copies of this thing yeah
freaking lunch and it took a
surprisingly long time to find it i
couldn't find it anywhere
and you have images of these things
right you take pictures of all these
things yeah i have images of that and i
um
yeah i don't uh i don't have any of the
original documents there's um left
everything with the archive which where
it should be but you didn't smuggle any
out
not saying that the temptation wasn't
there because some of the archives that
i you know went to um you know they're
uh
some of their record-keeping you know
has a little bit uh to be desired and
you want to protect you know this
history you know
uh but no i never know that it's all
there but yes found the report and um
uh
yeah holding it is a little weird
holding a lot of these documents because
you you know you haven't touched or
most likely no one's touched some of
this stuff yeah
since they were
printed off or typed off or whatever
you have here according to buckley this
is the report according to buckley the
battle required something not unlike the
riverine force used in
the american civil war in which said
abraham lincoln uncle sam's webbed feet
had fought not only in the deep sea and
the broad bay but also up the narrow
muddy bayou and wherever the ground was
a little damp
what a great i mean he quotes freaking
abraham lincoln this report this guy's
crafty for an unconventional example in
a modified amphibious environment
buckley could have drawn attention to
his own legacy
he didn't he never did so humility
lincoln's fleet was example enough in
practical terms his solution for the
navy heretofore failure was a
comprehensive overhaul of the entire
counter-infiltration effort
and you talk about this idea of
counter-infiltration as opposed to as
opposed to counter insurgency they want
to keep the the infiltrators the
communists from pushing into south
vietnam it's a blockade i mean that's
it's a traditional navy mission maybe he
doesn't understand counter insurgency
maybe much more comfortable with with a
blockade right and and so therefore
according therefore more navy boats more
navy boarding teams more riverine
checkpoints submarine nets navigation
lights a system for checking cargo
manifests and enforcing enforcing
curfews and in exchange for all this
more navy representation in four core
planning
on the question of whether the navy was
missing the boat on counter insurgency
the winning of the locals
loyalty through civic action and leading
the indigenous troops buckley's report
was comparatively silent especially
given the date just 86 days since
kennedy's assassination though he
recommended increased boat supports to
special forces camps he already judged
the green beret's efforts as slow and
time consuming and therefore ineffective
fast forward a little bit in its 46
pages the report used the term counter
insurgency only two times or sorry only
three times a somewhat nebulous field
buckley would one day call it four fewer
mentions than the term counter
infiltration
the report's preferred mission
appearing a total of ten times was a
variant of the term raiding a tactic
that could
said the report engender more fight back
spirit
amongst the rag sailors though those
were the south vietnamese trained
riverine sailors but would require
companies of pursuit raiders preferably
marines or rangers
and who would accompany such
and who would command such raids on this
question the former scout raider turned
seiko gorilla did not blink the over
water transport of raiding and landing
forces should be a navy responsibility
um
yeah that i mean that that part alone i
mean the fact that he doesn't even
mention seals in that i mean
clearly the navy thinks like i mean if
there's not like a little you know
uh you know that when the teacher you
know pounds on the chalkboard and says
hey you might want to remember this for
the test like that's what he's saying
like hey
don't you guys think that you want to be
doing this mission
and the army in the marine corps is like
nah
crazy
uh nine days later on february 25th 1964
the buckley report the name by which
even mcnamara would refer to it was
officially distributed to leaders across
the navy mack v and the joint chiefs of
staff eventually rising to the office of
secretary of defense it was handled said
buckley like a hot potato
actually was more like a gauntlet a
challenge to the navy's leaders to not
only directly fight an inland river war
but to fight it in a way that mostly
deviated from the consensus strategy of
counter insurgency over the next two
years this challenge would propel the
navy toward the development of new
vessels new organizations and most
importantly new missions including the
report's most recommended
rating beyond the riverbanks
so there it is
from there
the seals start creeping inland that's
what starts happening um
and and here's the intro that i started
this this podcast out with um that one
seal team one deck golf billy macon
that's what's happening um from there
they start they start making adjustments
to training
um
right this is the navy has set up the
seal teams they haven't created i mean
they've created the seal teams but they
haven't uh determined what the seal
teams are going to be they've raised
them like any parent was going to raise
a child they like planted a seed right
but the child is ultimately going to be
the one who decides what his future is
going to be like and they you know all
of this has come together into this last
you know last two chapters like
here we are
uh
and and you know they they have trouble
in the beginning they're almost sent
home the seals almost completely missed
the war
anyway they you uh
some so that the guys start coming back
from those vietnam deployments and like
i said they start making adjustments
because they're they're creeping more
and more inland um i i like this some of
these things
some of these things just warm my heart
because because i'm so connected to them
right so here we go back to the book
frustrated with the enemy's retreat from
the wrong sats riverbanks that golf had
already started pushing further inland
so far in fact that seal team one's
replacement platoons were now
anticipating almost nothing but
helicopter insertions
so we're we might not even be in the
water at all not even next to a river to
better prepare for this inland land
warfare seal team one's anderson had
ordered guy stone a former korean war
soldier and forward observer who had
left the army to become an enlisted seal
to create a six-week long pre-deployment
course in basic infantry tactics
with a training camp carved into the
chocolate mountains some 100 miles east
of the pacific ocean stone had trained
his team one comrades in every skill of
soldiering that he knew everything from
contour navigating to mortars every
skill a step closer to navy infantrymen
to the commanders now convened in
coronado such developments seemed to
justify an official revision to the
navy's
to the seals navy imposed operational
boundaries in other words what delgeudus
anderson and earley were describing as
direct missions outside of a purely
naval or maritime environment
as they already knew there was only one
other available area that could present
a navy unit with that kind of
opportunity an area contemporary descri
contemporary a contemporary described as
the war's true bastion of iron the
mekong delta
yeah i i've had some uh some vietnam
seals on here but that connection to our
west coast desert training facility
that's it man like that's you go out
there and you know i had roger hayden on
here was a vietnam i know roger yeah
just uh well that's right you worked at
warcom
but he was you know he'd start talking
about being out there at the desert
training facility and
like uh they set up the point man course
where they put booby traps and targets
and all that
like that's what i did when i got still
team one you went out there and you did
the point man course everybody did the
appointment course that came directly
from these guys in vietnam
so these things are um
you can still you can still still have
that thread
yeah
[Applause]
gonna push forward a little bit
get into some um
some of these stories that you you you
get from
the fighting that the seals start doing
as they push in and this is the this is
where the reputation really starts to
stand strong
i'm going to jump into the middle of a
mission here realizing that the enemy
was already moving to cut them off
gallagher decided the only thing left to
do was fight
this decision made he directed his men
to make for the only cover around a lone
peasant's house but 20 just 20
uncomfortable yards away from the
nearest tree line when they reached it
their first job was to calm the family
inside not an easy task for any home
invader and one in which the squad was
only partially successful as two
children quickly escaped sure to
eventually tell the viet cong their
position next most important was to
check the wounded yaw's entire entire
left side was starting to freeze up and
fix whatever was wrong with the radio
the same troubleshooting checklist of
cleaning connectors swapping out
handsets changing batteries plus a
healthy amount of cursing and praying
this troubleshooting however was only
partially successful
when ture finally got the radio back
online the only other person who could
hear him was jack rowell the radio man
for 7a and they had problems of their
own
at a little before 3am peterson and
squad 7a
considered themselves in a very
difficult position everywhere they
looked in the surrounding tree line
there was movement at one point peterson
had even seen torches what seemed like
hundreds of them moving toward their
south
but as they were now finding out over
the radio it could have been even worse
once gallagher and seven b's situation
was learned peterson was quick to count
his blessing
first
he had none of gal gallagher's
casualties except for the lerp who had
shot the man peterson had meant to
interrogate every one of his men still
had a full load load out of ammunition
next was his position clear fields of
fire in every direction and the
cemeteries berm for cover even concrete
vaults if the enemy brought in his
mortars most important of all raoul's
radio is now working as it should
putting the squad in reach of army
slicks and navy sea wolves who were at
that moment on their way to seven a's
rescue or at least they had been
recognizing 7b's overwhelming need
peterson quickly made two decisions
first he ordered raul to relay seven b's
position to the helicopters effectively
putting his own squad at the back of the
line
second and this decision was made by
default of the first 7a would now fight
the encircling enemy alone
just as peterson's decision was made and
the helicopters began diverting south a
group of some 30 viet cong fighters as
if sensing 7a's sudden vulnerability
stepped clear of the eastern wood line
spread themselves into a scream screen
of skirmishers and started forward
the first wave was coming and no one
knew what was coming behind it
having been forced to fend the spend the
first few minutes at the farmhouse
calming peasants dressing wounds and
fixing the radio gallagher despite
shards of metal in his legs was now
checking each man's field of fire and
telling him to hold that fire until he
gave the order
as men organized their positions with
easily accessible stacks of ammunition
and grenades they scanned their sectors
for any sign of movement they didn't
have to scan line
scan long soon between the rice bales
there was movement everywhere
look at them all said boynton it looks
like hundreds of them
but as best he could tell hundreds who
by their milling around still had no
idea where the americans were
right about the time that boynton was
making that assessment hook tour
received what they had been quietly
desperate for the check-in procedures
from lieutenant commander myers of the
navy sea wolves who rattled off the
loadout for his flight of two
helicopters wings racked with 2.75 inch
rockets and machine guns then gave his
altitude and vicinity a racetrack in the
sky far enough away so as to not reveal
7b's position
in response tear gave a physical
description of the rice paddy and seven
bees location in it along with the
rapidly deteriorating situation multiple
wounded and enemy everywhere
the next call was the lead pilot of the
army's flight of slicks who upon hearing
of 7b's situation
replied he would not be able to help as
it was a quote violation of squadron
policy to land in a hot lz end quote
what happened next is a matter of some
dispute one account suggests that the
sea wolf pilots may have shamed their
army peers by offering to pick up the
seals themselves or at least the wounded
the navy fuselages could only handle one
or two men
another explicitly claims that the sea
wolf commander told the army pilot
you're going to go down or i'm going to
shoot you down
whatever the truth within a few minutes
the matter was resolved and gallagher
told ture to tell the helicopters what
he wanted
at a little before 3 15 a.m the moon
behind him two seawolves started their
attack run across the rice paddy as they
closed with the tree line someone in the
squad there is some dispute as to who
stepped out of the farmhouse ripped the
pole ring on a mark 13 signal flare and
tossed it in the grass
within a second the flare ignited a
bonfire size glow that told the pilots
exactly where the seals were but also
drew the bullet snaps of every muzzle
now blazing from the tree line
as the seals flinched beneath the fire
and responded with their own the world
above them exploded with the womp womp
of the two gunships strafing the enemy's
muzzle flashes with their rockets and
four machine guns
with the landing skids directly above
them the combination of rotor blades and
rocket exhaust nearly ripped the roof
off roof off the farmhouse as the sea
wolves unleashed this chaos several
seals got online and followed suit
launching grenades and shredding through
belts of stoner rounds they had so as so
linked
the noise was unbelievable wrote one man
afterward and it looked like something
not of this world
behind this cover the army pilot
reluctantly landed his slick and
gallagher directed the firing line of
seals to begin bounding back toward it
while the firing line covered mike
boynton transformed himself into an
ambulance cradling men from the hooch to
the helicopter then helping to shoulder
yaw to a seat crammed between the pilot
and co-pilot finding gallagher limping
away from the firing line his rifle
still in hand and compressing a fresh
gunshot wound and leaning into the rotor
wash like it was a driving rain boynton
picked him up and heaved him so hard
into the helicopter's open door that he
flew right out the other side
that accident forced boynton to run all
the way around the helicopter and repeat
the effort finally stashing gallagher
all the way in the back
once everyone was finally loaded the
pilot eagerly applied his collective
pitch control lever until several knocks
on the helmet forced him to look back
hey we've still got men on the ground
boynton yelled above the the noise
at this the pilot depressed his
collective just in time for roy matthews
the barrel of his stoner glowing hot red
to dash from the hooch and clamber
aboard round's now clanking against the
fuselage
this time the pilot's liftoff sent a
shutter throughout the entire helicopter
prompting yaw to crane his head toward
the dash where he saw an rpm indicator
flashing red
while gaining the next hundred feet of
elevation the helicopter shook like it
would suddenly drop out of the sky a
feeling that only intensified when every
gun still connected to a living
communist finger started firing and
surrounding the slick with green tracers
it was a barrage that had resulted from
the near simultaneous liftoff of the sea
wolves because they had somewhere else
to be
[Music]
yeah i mean then you you go in to um
talk about how how they go now and
take care of peterson and and seven
alpha
um i mean the the uh
if i had written any slower this would
not have been written because the uh you
know
a lot of the guys that
gave me the stories from this thing are
no longer here ron yaw just passed away
a couple of months ago men just died bob
gallagher died
i mean all this history is you know very
very slowly but it's happening i mean
um one of the last things that uh
um
uh pete peterson well
one of the last interactions i had with
pete because pete was more than generous
with his time to do interviews with us
but one of the last things that he did
was um i sent him a galley copy of the
book
before it published
to get it in bob gallagher's hands so he
could see this i wanted you know
um
every you know all the folks that i
interviewed for from seven platoon the
one person that would not be interviewed
as bob gallagher
he um
that said
i still was
anxious for him to know
you know the legacy and the contribution
that he had you know not just to the
seal teams but to
you know establishing you know what
ultimately the seal teams became the
mission that the seal teams have um
so sent the copy of the book to pete uh
pete drove it over to bob's house
um
and
pete you know didn't get any information
on whether or not he actually read it
but um after bob passed
they found the the copy of the book in
his house
with a note inside that said to
uh pass this book on to his best friend
so hopefully very hopefully he uh he was
able to at least see this yeah well then
that's a good indication
um
you say here when this was done he
submitted awards as peterson submitted
awards up through ctf 116's chain of
command bronze stars for just about
every one of every member of seven bravo
a silver star for boynton and for
gallagher a navy cross an award
that he had to justify to an awards
officer with multiple statements but who
responded by saying that the evidence
could actually support a medal of honor
i
i hope it does i mean i
i think they're
that would be
that would be really great if uh this
could act as something of a record for
maybe an adjustment of some of these
awards
we'll see yeah
i mean right now i think we got
gallagher and watson
um
but uh yeah and you know one of the you
know
great things uh or one of the most
interesting things about that episode is
that peterson submits himself for
nothing
i mean how many uh how many officers or
how many people do we work with you know
over the you know course of our careers
that
you know their preoccupation was you
know what awards they're going to get
out of this awards are um are one of
those funny things that you know they
don't always necessarily
uh you know say what the person you know
deserves
they often say you know how good their
chain of command was and recognizing you
know what they you know what they got
100 awards are
crazy awards say just as they say as
much about the person that submits them
for it as it does about the person
himself i mean i had i had a guy saw a
guy on here
dick thompson
um
got got into a helo to to like set up
the spy rig or something
during a bright light operation
ends up the tilo just takes off he's
getting ready to go and leave he's
getting ready to go on liberty so he
doesn't even have his weapon he doesn't
have a gear with him
and the helo takes off to go on this
bright light to go and rescue downed
guys
they can't get in he ends up throwing a
rope out rappelling down grabs the crew
chief's gun repels down no gloves burns
his hand gets in there rescues people
recovers body from two different
helicopters completely it's complete oh
by the way he he dropped down
the rope ended and he drops into 150
foot canopy and just drops just lets go
and just falls through the freaking
jungle canopy to get in there it's it's
totally insane
he gets done with that i mean there's no
possible way he should live number one
and no no way should he have actually
rescued guys he lives he rescues he gets
like a bronze star
it's freaking totally insane
and you know here's the other thing um
about and what's what and you you you
lay this out very clearly um a very
important thing about this seal team two
seventh platoon
what really they were doing great
operations but what really made it
important was that they were doing these
intel driven raids then they were
gathering intelligence they were
exploiting that intelligence and they
were doing follow-on raids so this set
like a a standard um
it
creates our cycle of operations
and what's important about that is you
know we didn't
i try and tell everybody that i meet
that the seal teams
we didn't invent ourselves we didn't
everything good about us we took from
somebody else if anything the seal teams
are just an aggregate of all the best
pieces of all these other units that
have come before us
and
not just navy units either we took the
best parts of the rangers we took the
best parts of the raiders and we
combined all that and when we didn't
know how to do something we found the
best person to teach us how to do it and
they taught us how to do it and we took
it
um
and same thing when it comes to this cat
the cycle of capture kill i mean we i
mean we sort of stumbled upon it and i
think um
uh you know
with guys like pete peterson and bob
gallagher who are really um you know
leveraging the information that they can
get from other units and then
aggregating that to to drive their own
operations i mean the guy like bob
wagner who's you know he is creating
essentially single-handedly creates the
prus and the
the pru is the best part about that is
it's this cycle of operations that they
get and that the seal teams sort of
notice like we can do that too
so
yeah the use of interpreters the use of
the locals that the use of the locals
not to build a guerrilla force but to
just to gather intelligence and go do
hits
and it's just i mean it's like you know
it's no different than what you know the
police do in every major city across the
country you arrest somebody you shake
them down for information and then you
go get the next person it's a cycle of
operations that just keep perpetuating
itself
so
um you got incredible sections in here
and again this whole book we we barely
even touch the surface of what you've
got in this book but i want to finish
off with this section here
it says this
last section i'm going to read
in march of 1969 the rand corporation a
semi-private think tank that specialized
in research and analysis for the
department of defense published
published a report titled
the navy seal commandos a case study of
military decision making and
organizational change
as far as i know the first academic
level study of the seal teams
the report's author was frances j bing
west a former force recon marine and
vietnam war veteran whose investigation
had begun a year earlier and by the way
you can read a bunch of his
books right now he wrote a bunch of
other books wrote books about
iraq
his investigation had begun a year
earlier and whose research had produced
a raft of documents dozens of interviews
and the first-hand observation of
several seal missions into the rung sat
and the mekong delta
so he went and observed what seals were
doing and this guy is a force recon
marine himself
from this research west had produced an
18-page report whose introduction
provided a brief description of seal
training training he estimated at a cost
of around 14 000 per man plus an
overview of the seal's commitment to
vietnam at its height a commitment that
never exceeded 150 seals or roughly 100
1 150 fewer than the in-country height
of the green beret's total compliment
it was a commitment that stood out in
even starker relief when placed next to
the author's obvious admiration for the
seal's progression from lackluster
coastal raiders to the war's most
aggressive direct action commandos
admittedly commandos who had no had had
no business becoming such and had thus
drawn the interest of the same
preeminent think tank that created the
us military's nuclear defense strategy
intended as a study on organizational
change
the report's true purpose had been to
discover how the navy could have
possibly succeeded in creating a
land-focused commando force a force that
even the viet cong had reportedly dubbed
the men with green faces a color not
normally associated with the navy's
traditional medium
it was a puzzle of personal importance
to the officer to the author as the
marine corps
the far more likely branch of service
had never succeeded in creating anything
similar
quote how the concept was shepherded
through the joint chiefs of staff and
congress i am still trying to determine
the author wrote
for the mission of the seals
exceeded the charter of the us navy
as best as he could tell the legality of
this infringement had been tolerated
because of its negligible size but later
had been allowed to widen because of a
series of factors none of which at this
point should be should come as a
surprise
the first of these now here you start
talking about how we ended up with this
with the seal teams the first of these
at least in the mekong delta submitted
the author had been the neglect of the
us army in general and the ninth
infantry division in particular to push
their commando type units
to the same to quote develop the same
aggressive attitude towards ambushing
that the seals had end quote it might
further be added that neither entity had
adequately prepared those commando type
units to make such a transition in the
delta environment
a claim best evidenced by one attempt to
conceal the river insertion of five lerp
soldiers by having them copy the seal
method of jumping from the back of a
moving boat
but that ultimately resulted in the
drowning of all five men
the second factor that accounted for
this infringement the report continued
had been the navy's senior officers
whose tours by comparison were mostly
dreary affairs a condition made more
noticeable when quote in the presence of
generals end quote
to compensate for this the navy's
leaders had allowed the seals more
latitude than they had their other units
a black market trade-off that it
produced a steady supply of anecdotes
for the navy and thereby quote saved the
pride of the admirals
end quote that's an interesting concept
like the the the admirals wanted
something to talk about
ultimately the author decided the most
important factors
factor in the seals infringement
was owing to the seals themselves and
the culture that weighed upon them
drawn from a notorious selective
training program that produced few
qualified candidates the seals naturally
had had to find a mission that kept
casualties low a circumstance that might
have pushed them like the lerps or
forced recon marines into a
reconnaissance role that they had anyone
to pass
had they had anyone to pass intelligence
onto so you're saying there look if you
got a small number of people
probably one of the safest missions you
can do
is hey we're gonna go into
reconnaissance where we're not supposed
to be seen we're not supposed to come in
contact with the enemy and and his and
bing west is saying here like they could
have gone in that direction they could
have gone into this reconnaissance role
had they had anyone to pass the
intelligence to
they hadn't
nor had there been any great pressure
from the riverine force to engage in any
sort of green beret style advisory duty
or civic action
so they didn't go in that direction
either they didn't go where yarbro went
hey let's go
raise a bunch of of uh
local guerrillas to fight
organizational orphans with no larger
force to support or control them and
possessing quote no love or administ or
admiration for the vietnamese end quote
the seals had set out into the swamps
not to prove themselves
their training had already done that
said the author but quote because
not to go
would have been inexcusable to the
others
they had developed a collective value
system which emphasized physical
hardiness and courage
and they liked to fight
that's just a beautiful thing
so so so the seals seals didn't have
this um you know you might talk to an
army green beret talking about hey i
like my little people you know the sod
guys call them little people they're
they're forming relationships with the
locals
this is a quote the seals had quote no
love or admiration for the vietnamese
end quote
that's crazy right
and then and then just to do that one
more to say that one more time
they weren't doing anything to prove
themselves they were doing it because
but quote because
not to go would have been inexcusable to
the others
they talk about the others like it's an
excuse if you don't go
you're not a seal you're not a seal it's
inexcusable to the other seals
they had developed a collective value
system which emphasized physical
hardness and courage and they liked to
fight end quote
so when the tactics of patrolling and
ambush had proved unproductive
nobody not a seal meaning no blue water
superior officer had ordered them to try
something else
they had just done it
it was an exceptional adaptation the
marine veteran author made a special
note to point out that his fellow
marines had failed to mimic
and by following the previous logic for
reasons that blamed them for this
a sequence of attribution and blame that
if the preceding pages approved anything
was not a sufficient explanation
quote what strikes me as most remarkable
about the seal story the author
concluded
is their performance and their ability
to learn and adapt in a decentralized
sub-optimizing environment end quote
though all true and commendable it was
also an explanation that it considered
only the record that came after 1966.
missing was any analysis that probed
deeper than that top layer of history
whose soil had fertilized this inland
evolution
the armies and marine corps preceding 30
years of whipsawing interest in raids
and raiders and the navy's perennial
preoccupation with justifying its worth
in offensive combat a preoccupation that
it combined with this navy's traditional
latitude and the udd's traditional
adaptability to create what several
unidentified seals soon described to a
documentary filmmaker as the war's
unsung soldier
and quote what we consider without
question the best troops that the
country has
end quote both descriptions notable
because they didn't use the word
sailors
and just short of the reader's digest
appraisal that had dubbed them the war's
quote super commandos
by the end
these would be assessments
that were next to impossible to dispute
here you're kind to uh end on
uh bing west's report that was one of
the first uh things i found i found that
at the udtco museums archives when i
started this book it was one of the
first places i went to do research and
the
archives at the udtco museum are a
little disorganized
and some cases that's
provides opportunities that you didn't
expect
and one of those was bing west report
and i had found it uh i read it uh when
i got it but i hadn't thought about it i
it had you know it provided enough
um kind of food for thought that it just
kind of stuck in the back of my head
stuck in the back of my head for at
least eight years
and so when i was you know nearing the
end of the book and i was trying to find
a way to you know kind of summarize
everything that had happened um you know
it suddenly dawned on me you know i'll
go back to that report and i knew that
it had been written by francis j
west i didn't know it was bing west
it was like oh my gosh it's bing west
like and i've read you know books by
bing west and not only that but in a way
that you know it made this thing even
more like uh just strange that it
happened but
uh on one of the last ops that we did in
al-anbar province we had uh gotten uh my
uh platoon had been ambushed on a
rooftop uh
sniper overwatch
and uh one of our one of our seals mark
robbins had been shot through the
through the head he took a bullet a 762
round from a pkm through his right eye
and exited the back of his head
and we were cut off from support we
couldn't get any i was trying to get
aircraft down to support us they
wouldn't come they wouldn't come because
there were so much uh you know machine
gun fire
uh and we were trying to uh
uh
get the other seal uh element to fight
to our position and they were they just
were they were on foot and trying to get
there as quickly as possible
so
at one point i asked for a you know a
marine qrf and the marine qrf was
separated from us at the fob by this
road that we
we called ied alley we'd never known a
vehicle to drive on this road and had
not gotten ied'ed
and
one officer who was there a major he
jumps in a humvee grabs another humvee
and they start trucking down the road to
to get to our position they get to us
they provide cover for the helicopter to
get in
uh and we mark actually you know it
walks himself to the helicopter uh
remarkably he's still around he's a lake
county cop now and yeah
um
but
what makes this you know story even more
remarkable is that the marine major who
came to our rescue was owen west
west son as soon as you started telling
i knew exactly where the story was going
i was like this has to be old west this
has to be a big second i mean it's just
incredible i think the the uh and and
bing was you know the the fact that bing
wrote this report bing had this uh
interaction with the seal teams in 1960
68 and then writes this report in 1969
super humble report too
incredibly super generous and i mean you
have so many opportunities to you know
draw attention to other things and he
doesn't i mean he's he's he's truly
impressed by this organization
what you know
we you know as a
as a server as an institution have not
done which i think we should do at every
opportunity is recognize the uh the
influence that all of these other units
had on our creation
soldiers marines rangers uh recon
everybody they've all contributed to who
we are in some sense
our history i think it's i mean
and especially if you frame it in this
way
it's not our history it is our history
but it's a lens that you can use
to to look at the entire history of
american special operations from world
war ii to vietnam
we wouldn't be here without them and in
some ways they would not have changed
into the unit so they wouldn't have
permanently created these units had we
not set an example for them to also
follow
yeah i mean it's um
and you know
the the thing with bing west and just
that humble
report that you can you can
i mean the marine corps is just so
professional in so many ways it reminds
me of dave burke who was a
top gun pilot f-18 pilot marine corps
fighter pilot um
ended up being the
senior instructor at top gun
um f-35 pilot f-22 this is a total stud
um and he worked with us he was a fact
with us on the ground in the battle or
mahdi what's really interesting is you
know he came from top gun he was the
senior instructor at top gun i mean you
you're not you're not going to get any
more professional of a human being
as a marine that is the senior
instruction instructor at top gun
and i was talking to him about when he
came to one of our briefs for the first
time this is we're in the battle of
maudi we're doing a brief some kind of
an operation
and
he was just telling me right away he was
just so impressed with what what just
how the brief was just how the brief was
you know this is young lieutenant leif
babin and and chief tony of fratty
getting up there and talking about what
we're gonna do me giving the commander's
intent and like
i remember him telling me that this was
ten years later he probably told me that
and just that humility to think oh
these guys are doing something that is
that is squared away and and for being
to be able to recognize that
and write that while the war is still
going on
um that's pretty impressive and and you
know you say that he he
didn't really probe deeper than the
layer of history that's prior to 1966
but um i'll tell you what that left
plenty of room for you to do just that
with this book and and this book
which provides so much history so much
information
um
thank you and
you know you know one thing that is
awesome about the marine corps and i've
talked about this on this podcast before
i actually talk a lot about it with
clients because the marine corps has an
incredibly powerful culture
uh i think it might be the strongest
culture in the world absolutely i
couldn't agree more i
yeah i
i've said it you know time and time
again like pound for pound there is no
institution like the us marine corps
their uh their ability to um
they they require um much more from
everybody from from their uh their
troops than every other branch of
service the trade-off though with with
that by requiring as much
is a level of responsibility that nobody
else gets in the military
and the result is
it's initiative and courage
and that initiative and courage is part
of
it's part of their culture
and if you you know i i thought about
this for years as i was doing this
podcast and interviewing people and what
the marine corps has
is this culture that is rooted
in the stories of their history
and i think that what you've done with
this book
will strengthen
the history of the frogman and the seal
teams and it'll anchor our culture
to a past
that is
filled with these qualities that we want
these qualities of bravery and heroism
and and adaptation and evolution
and
pride from our successes and humility
from our failures and i think this book
connects us with the individuals
[Music]
who pave the way for us that we are
lucky enough to be associated with and
lucky enough really to call our brothers
and make this incredible group of
individuals
that we call the teams
and it's an outstanding book and i think
you've done a real service to the
community by writing this book
and anybody if you're in the seal teams
absolutely just order this book
immediately there's an audiobook version
which is outstanding as well
get this book anybody that has any
interest in any
military history in
the history of all special operations
just get this book there's so much
information in it it's it's immaculately
researched
and i just i couldn't be i couldn't be
more impressed with it man and i'm
look i feel i feel somewhat bad because
i write books
basically from my own head and it feels
like i i have a much easier task than
you do i don't have to read anything i
just write what i already know or what i
live through and uh for you to dive so
deep into this it's just outstanding and
i think it's it's um
a huge
a huge service to the teams man thank
you so thanks ben
echo charles you got anything
well i think we covered it you know it's
good to see you
thank you nice to see you again
hey ben um where can we find you i know
you gotta you got a twitter right is
that is that pretty much your your
social media extent uh i have a twitter
and an instagram i probably should
create uh facebook because i think
there's you know a few older people that
would yeah like that side what's your
what's your i know your twitter is ben h
milligan right what's your what's your
gram
i'm new to this so please bear with me
i'm getting better uh b milligan three b
milligan three yeah b milligan and then
i've got three i've got three little
boys so that's uh okay
yeah and um
do you have a website or anything i love
no i don't find anything i mean
i'm not i'm just like the
um
i'm the most incapable person when it
comes to social media and promotion what
i always say is the same
personality traits that make it possible
to write this book are the same
personality traits that make it hard to
promote it
so i um i'm doing the best i can i
appreciate you bringing me on here uh
the uh
yeah i couldn't have done this with
without lots of people helping out and
including everybody that you know came
together to you know get this to admiral
mcraven um
you know to to get that uh that blur
from him and then um
you know i
couldn't have written it without just uh
uh my you know the support of all the
people around me including
the three little guys that i wrote this
for so
well hey man
once again
thanks for your thanks for your service
and the navy great thanks for your
service to the teams
thanks for doing what you did um
and and really truly
honestly man i can't thank you enough
for writing this book and it's it's just
it's just an outstanding document i hope
everybody gets it so much to learn and
so much respect to be paid to the
forefathers that brought us to where we
are today thanks for shining a light on
them for us thank you
and with that
ben milligan has left the building
uh echo charles yes sir
need to uphold
the legacy of the teams
by getting better what do you got for us
all right
first off side note me and ben have
history
one of the first people
that i met
in san diego when i moved here
yep
because of the connection between cake
machines yep through uh my hawaii people
you know that came to me to eventually
become seals
he was one of the first he didn't
remember you though well here's the
thing we both zero we both no no no no
no no no no no zero was inaccurate zero
is inaccurate he was like looking at me
i was like i was like maybe a little
something then later on the break yeah
we reconnected yeah once you described
exactly the situation because he didn't
remember you
either way we're all trying to get
better which is weird you know when
someone's got such an eye for detail
and he doesn't remember you at all
that's got to hurt a little bit yeah
especially all the all the research he's
done and like all the stuff that his
brain is like capable of you don't even
make mustard disney
mustard thing bro
either way we're connected now we're
pretty much boys again so it's all good
and you know we are trying to get better
as you mentioned yeah so boom we're over
here we're working out we're working out
we're reading not as much as ben but we
well most of us not as much of that but
we're trying
gotta stay cognitively and physically in
the game and improving ourselves slowly
quickly whatever i'm saying through this
journey we need supplementation
good news chocolate supplements
called jacqueline fuel first one to talk
about is the energy drink new paradigm
i said it paradigm
new era of energy drinks no longer are
we burdened
burdened
with the poisons and the aftermath and
the price
of bad energy drinks it's all good all
good tastes good
gives you the little boost we need
and healthy for you has electrolytes too
by the way which is is that ever a thing
electrolytes sometimes you need them
yeah well no no to have them is a thing
yes i didn't i don't know if other
energy drinks have electric things
they don't fit because there's too much
poison in the other ones yeah yeah
here's the interesting thing you look at
the way the seal teams came to fruition
right
there was a gap there's gaps and some
people enter the gap but then they leave
it right they do that but the seal teams
are just there the udts are just there
we're staying with it yeah that's sort
of like the this whole situation we're
finding ourselves in
because there is little gap oh no
everyone wants to make poison because it
sells put a bunch of sugar in it put a
bunch of caffeine in it and just give
people poison and don't care
that's the gap
the gap is like hey people might
actually want something that's healthy
yeah and so i've seen now that we win in
the gap there's other people that are
trying to get in there but they don't
believe in it
so as soon as they realize
how expensive it is how hard it is
produced as soon as they realize that
they just leave the gap so we're just
there solo operations cruising standing
tall
like the damn seal teams this is the
freaking seal teams of of drinks right
here jacob discipline go
that's what's happening oh yeah
delivering and that's the thing and you
know what i'm accomplishing the mission
at all costs i'm not telling anyone to
be offended i'm not saying that in fact
i would never say that
i'm not telling people to be angry i'll
never say that
i can't i can't impose outrage on
somebody
that being said
those other
entities that created these old-school
old era
energy drinks
they're kind of playing on your weekend
they're they're taking us for fools
they're taking advantage they're like
humans they're like hey hey this is this
tastes real good you know the guy in the
alley you know with the red eyes or
whatever
yeah yeah hey hey take the bruh it
tastes good tastes good skinny you're
gonna really nice nice little boost
meanwhile you're like cool you buy it
you drink it you enjoy the whatever you
enjoy and then later on when that guy's
long gone
you're over here paying the price yeah
and it's not even like monetary cocaine
addicted less healthy all this stuff
let's see and here comes jocko
that's good good finally finally here we
go all right we're on discipline go in
the can boom
uh yeah so display and also discipline
the supplement itself there's powder yep
there's capsules as well just you know
you're on the go whatever different
different deployment methods you know
also joint warfare
oil krill oil these are for your joints
vitamin d3 and cold water that's for
immunity milk additional protein in the
form of a dessert yeah so good this will
never change it was so good the only
thing that was it hits the lips evolved
with this is new flavors i hear about
new flavors
maybe some cookies
i said it but i said it
i'm not saying i'm just saying i said it
um also chocolate white tea if you know
about that that's
the ogt that jocko drinks is in
and it was and still is into yeah it's
good probably if you like deadlifting
eight thousand pounds you like that tea
yeah yeah they go hand in hand 100
and you can get all these things at
the energy drinks wah-wah
everything else including without
limited to the energy drinks
jackalful.com yup if you subscribe to
him if you want just to come to your
house like
like as reliable as a udt frogman
getting to the beach that's how you want
your supplements to show up just
subscribe
jackalfuel.com it'll come and be free
shipping by the way because we're up
against some some competitors we're up
against the imperial japanese army and
the nazis sure so we're gonna we're
gonna have to sneak in under the radar
here yep that's what we're doing i
understand fully also vitamin shop you
get the stuff at vitamin shop
so yeah you just appreciate it grab
something easy money vitamin chop also
origin origin usa this is where you can
get your american-made stuff look not
it's not just printed in america it is
printed in america but not just printed
in america same same we go all the way
back oh gee to the roots
the seeds
the seeds of the plant that made the
seeds
all
all made and planted grown sown in
america everything
american-made denim
there's some leather in there there's a
lot of a lot of awesome materials but
you got boots you got jeans you got um
jiu jitsu stuff yeah you got a lot of
stuff on there to stuff i there's a
couple places where they mentioned
that's kind of training was going on
back in the day back there like can you
just imagine these guys like hey we're
gonna train you with demolitions blowing
things up underwater swimming small boat
handling jiu jitsu they're doing it all
yeah
so get some of that origin usa
tested out some boots at camp yeah hey
look i'm not gonna go into it
but those are some yeah yeah impressive
i don't even really wear that many boots
on that many occasions but that one was
like
that could coerce me into wearing boots
look at you as far as coordination goes
check
origin originusa.com.com
also jacqueline's a store it's called
jacques store and this is where you can
get your discipline equals freedom stuff
hats hoodies shirts
also good also other stuff there's good
stuff on there little developments going
on over there
anyway jacquelinestore.com
over here
look at you it's it's top secret until
you go there then it's like boom secret
it is revealed real secret but you can
go to the website yes sir yes sir
available to everybody
um but
reveal your new uh shirt
oh yeah your shirt locker sure you like
them
because we're making the shirt locker on
youtube the sherlocker if you want a
cool t-shirt that and this is this is
what i've leaned toward the whole time
is shirts that are kind of tied to the
podcast
and this is one of them right here the
sea wolves 1966 to 1972. by the way
commissioned in combat
decommissioned in combat that's the sea
wolves you heard about them today if
they will go and get the seals out of
the worst possible situations gunfire
don't care that's true so how do you get
that shirt sherlocker yes what's up the
the one of the
homages to the sea wolves
very much though oh you can get this at
the shirt locker on jocko's store
oh so yeah you sign up for the shirt
locker you get a cool shirt
cool
it's hard for me to explain how cool it
is varying levels
of
creativity either wear a school shirt
you get one every month free shipping on
that one as well this is just one of
them
i got a new feature that we're working
on it should be done should be done
within the next i don't know but if you
remember the shirt locker hey look you
missed a shirt
last month five months ago whatever
you'll have the option to get it if you
remember
oh yeah we're working on that one
nonetheless yes very nicely this is the
shirt i'm glad you like it jocko uh
seems you know people seem to like the
designs overall well you know this is
just one of them so yeah
i bet people like that one
a lot
because i like that one a lot well
because i'm a supporter of the sea
wolves
hey subscribe also to this podcast we
also have some other podcasts unraveling
that i do with my brother dc daryl
cooper we got the grounded podcast we
got the warrior kid podcast we also have
jacounderground.com
which we release a little
uh what's it called a little alternative
podcast a little complimentary podcast
where we talk about some other
adjacent items
and we do some q a
and
the reason we have that is in case
these platforms which we do not control
which we don't like
we want to be in control
so that we can deliver
and if people start inserting
advertisements into this podcast we we
know you don't want that we don't want
it
we'd rather have you listen to a
74-minute advertisement at the end where
echo charles is talking
hey
eight dollars and eighteen cents a month
if you want to help us out with the
jocko underground go to
jockowunderground.com if you can't
afford it no factor we're we we're in
this together
email assistants jockleunderground.com
we also have a youtube channel subscribe
to that we make awesome videos where i
am the assistant director and really the
driving sort of creative force beside
the awesomeness of most of the videos
and then echo does some editing for it
you're doing great work thank you orange
usa also origin usa cool uh uh channel
youtube channel oh yeah fully yeah
that's a good one if you're interested
in an american
company
their ups and downs challenges successes
yeah that's a really good one
also psychological warfare what that is
is an album with jocko tracks on it
tracks on the album draco talking
getting us through our moments of
weakness which we may or may not have
you know
either way you can get that uh anywhere
where you can get mp3's
psychological warfare good one if you
want something to hang on your wall
which you probably do you don't just
want to have walls that are just plain
and black you do well i guess i do but
if i didn't
then i would go to flipsidecanvas.com
and i would get some cool stuff from my
brother dakota meyer
who makes awesome stuff to hang on your
wall got a bunch of books look this book
today
by water beneath the walls by ben
milligan
this is an outstanding book it is an
outstanding book
i i can't i don't know what else to tell
you get this book
it's so good so much information so much
history if you have any interest if you
listen this podcast let me put it this
way if you listen this podcast you will
freaking love this book i love this book
it is awesome get it the it's just an
outstanding um also have final spin
coming out this is a novel
apparently allegedly possibly a novel
written by me
it's a story it's available now for
pre-order you want to get that first a
dish i have people coming up to me now
they're they're apologetic because
they're bringing me second a dish of
discipline equals freedom during second
the dish of leadership strategic
attackers don't you don't want to be
that person you don't have that that
that sort of sunken look on your face
you want to say i'm in the game
hey we have a little connection you got
that first edition we have a little
connection
i'm not i'm not saying don't talk to me
if you have a second edition a third
edition it's okay look i have an open
mind
but if you wanna
if you wanna have that immediate
connection
let's get that going
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation the
protocols this one was freedom field
manual
way of the warrior kid one two three and
four mikey and the dragons about face by
hackworth almost brought that up today
i almost brought that up today but you
know once you open that door who knows
when you're stopping
because he's got now that i think about
it he i didn't even mention this he's
got it in here what hackworth hackworth
was running the tiger force
i can't believe i didn't bring that up
i'm sorry ben i missed there's so much
think about how much information is in
there that i didn't bring up hackworth
that's crazy
so he's got hackworth tiger force what
happened to them why did they come about
how did they do why did they get turned
off there's a whole story behind it
once again that's that's by water
beneath the walls by ben milligan about
face i wrote the forward to the newest
version of that we got extreme ownership
in the dichotomy of leadership i have a
leadership consulting company called
echelon front we solve problems through
leadership go to
echelonfront.com for details on that
that's where you can find out about the
muster the field training exercises ef
battlefield we have a an event coming up
in las vegas
october 28th and 29th it's called the
muster come and get it
we also have
the ftx field training exercise that's
happening
next one is in st louis september 20th
and 21st probably
closest sold out i think we had a group
of people that couldn't make it so there
might be some openings check it out go
to go to ashlandfront.com we also have
online training an online leadership
training academy you need to go to the
gym to stay in shape you need to go to
extremeownership.com to keep your
leadership in shape
come and check it out if you want to
help service members active and retired
their families gold star families check
out mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
charity organization she does all kinds
of incredible things for veterans and if
you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to america's mighty
mightywarriors.org
and if you want any more of my
monotonous
monotony
monotone
or you need more of ekko's mystified
murmurs
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter
on the gram and on facebook echo is at
echo charles and i am at jocko wheeling
and ben milligan is on twitter at
ben h milligan
and his instagram is was it ben
mill three i don't know listen rewind it
it's b milligan three b milligan three
there you go m i l l i l-i-g-a-n
again thanks once again to ben for your
service in the navy your service and the
teams and now your incredible service to
the teams
by writing this incredible book that
will solidify our roots our culture and
our history can't thank you enough and
to all the military personnel out there
on the front lines right now
thank you for defending our freedom and
our way of life and to police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics and
emts dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol secret service and all
first responders
thanks for keeping us safe here at home
and everyone else out there how about we
all take a little lesson from these
frogmen
how about we develop and embrace a
collective value system that emphasizes
physical hardiness and courage an
attitude that can press on through pain
and suffering a humble intellect that
can adapt and overcome a discipline
that's unbreakable
and an unwavering commitment
to accomplish the mission
that is the way of the frogmen
that
is an ideal
example to follow
and the one
that i wake up and face every day
to hold the line
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out